ORDER GOOD AFTERNOON IN
RESPONSE TO THE COVERT NINETEEN
EMERGENCY AND TO PROTECT THE
PUBLIC SENATORS AND SENATE
STAFF WE MUST LIMIT
NONESSENTIAL GATHERINGS AND IT
HERE TO SOCIAL DISTANCING. IN
COMPLIANCE WITH THOSE ORDERS
THE SENATE WILL BE HOLDING AN
ESSENTIAL HEARING AND HAS MADE
NECESSARY ADJUSTMENTS TO NORMAL
PRACTICES IN ORDER TO ENSURE
THAT THE PUBLIC CONTINUES TO
HAVE ACCESS TO THE LEGISLATIVE
PROCESS. WELL CONDUCTING THE
HEARING IN A WAY THAT PROTECTS
THE HEALTH AND SAFETY OF THE
PUBLIC AND OUR EMPLOYEES TO
ALLOW THE PUBLIC ACCESS WE HAVE
ADMITTED MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
TO TWO HEARING ROOMS TO THE
EXTENT THAT SOCIAL DISTANCING
REQUIREMENTS ALLOW. AND WILL BE
USING A TELECONFERENCE SERVICE
FOR THOSE INDIVIDUALS WHO WISH
TO TESTIFY TODAY. FOR ALL
INDIVIDUALS WISHING TO PROVIDE
PUBLIC COMMENT THE PARTICIPANT
TOLL FREE NUMBER AND ACCESS
CODE IS POSTED ON OUR COMMITTEE
WEBSITE IT WILL BE DISPLAYED ON
THE SCREEN AND I WILL NOT SIT
HERE NOW. TODAY PARTICIPANT
NUMBER IS ONE EIGHT EIGHT
EIGHT. TWO SEVEN SIX. EIGHT
SEVEN ZERO THREE AND THE ACCESS
CODE IS. EIGHT TWO SIX THREE
SEVEN SEVEN TWO LET ME REPEAT.
ONE EIGHT EIGHT EIGHT TWO SEVEN
SIX EIGHT SEVEN ZERO THREE. AND
THE ACCESS CODE IS EIGHT TWO
SIX THREE. SEVEN SEVEN TWO.
WHEN WE MOVED TO PUBLIC COMMENT
TO A MODERATOR WILL IDENTIFY
YOU INDIVIDUALLY OPEN YOUR LINE
AND AT THAT TIME YOU MAY
ADDRESS THE COMMITTEE. NOTE
THAT IN ORDER FOR US TO HEAR
YOU CLEARLY AND TO AVOID
ACOUSTIC FEEDBACK. YOU MUST
MUTE THE DEVICE YOU WERE
WATCHING THE HEARING ON PRIOR
TO GIVING TESTIMONY OVER THE
PHONE. IT IS IMPORTANT THAT WE
HEAR FROM YOU AND WE THANK YOU
FOR YOUR PATIENCE TODAY. I WILL
MAINTAIN DECORUM DURING THE
HEAT HEARING AS IS CUSTOMARY.
IN ANY INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE
DISRUPTIVE MAY BE REMOVED FROM
THE REMOTE MEETING SERVICE OR
HAVE THEIR CONNECTIONS MUTED.
WHILE EVERY EFFORT HAS BEEN
MADE TO STREAMLINE THE HEARING
PROCESS AND CONDUCT OUR
HEARINGS IN AS CLOSE TO THE
SAME MANNER AS IS CUSTOMARY.
THERE MAY BE SOME LAG TIMES FOR
PARTICIPANTS WHO ARE ADJUSTING
TO THE USE OR NEW ONLINE TOOLS
OR TECHNOLOGIES.
FOR THOSE ON
THE CALL TODAY LOOKING TO
PROVIDE TESTIMONY. I GAVE YOU
AN INCORRECT NUMBER. I WILL
GIVE YOU A CORRECT NUMBER IN A
MOMENT. TO THOSE INDIVIDUALS
WISHING TO PROVIDE PUBLIC
COMMENT THE PARTICIPANT TOLL
FREE NUMBER AND ACCESS CODE. IS.
818-442-9163 SIX FOUR. AND THE
ACCESS CODE IS. EIGHT TWO SIX
THREE SEVEN SEVEN TWO LET ME
REPEAT. 944-291-6364 IN THE
ACCESS CODE IS. EIGHT TWO SIX
THREE SEVEN SEVEN TWO. SO WHILE
EVERY EFFORT HAS BEEN MADE TO
STREAMLINE THE PROCESS THERE
MAY BE SOME LAG TIMES FOR
PARTICIPANTS WHO ARE ADJUSTING
TO THE USE OF THE NEW ONLINE
TOOLS OR TECHNOLOGIES. PLEASE
BE RESPECTFUL AND PATIENT TO
SHOW ALL INTERESTED PARTIES CAN
BE HEARD. SO WE WILL NOW BEGIN
THE HEARING TODAY WE HAVE SIX
BILLS ON TODAY'S AGENDA. AND
BEFORE WE HEAR PRESENTATION ON
THE BILL'S LET'S ESTABLISH A
QUORUM. UNDERSECRETARY WOULD
YOU PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. AND
PLEASE REMEMBER MEMBERS TO TURN
YOUR MICROPHONES ON BEFORE YOU
SPEAK. HILL HERE HE'LL HEAR
MORE LOCK PRESIDENT MORE LIKE
PRESENCE. BRADFORD EASIER
BRADFORD HERE. CHIANG HERE
CHIANG HERE. DAWALY HERE DOLLY
HERE DODD YOUR DOT HERE.
HERTZBERG. MCGUIRE. PAN. RUBIO
PRESIDENT WITH A PRESENT.
SKINNER HERE SKINNER HERE.
STERN HERE STERN HERE. WIENER.
JERRY HAVE PORN THANK YOU MADAM
SECRETARY WE DO HAVE A QUORUM
SO WE WILL BEGIN OUR HEARING
TODAY AND I WILL TURN THE-
HEARING OVER TO IN THE GAVEL
VIRTUALLY OVER TO THE VICE
CHAIR CENTER MORE LOCK FOR THE
FIRST A BILL THANK THE CHERRY
HILL WE'RE GOING TO START WITH
SENATE BILL. FIFTY EIGHT WHICH
IS BY SENATOR HUESO. WAS UNABLE
TO MAKE IT TODAY SO THE WORLD
FAMOUS JURY HILL. SENATOR WILL
BE PRESENTING SENATOR WAY SAYS
BILL. AND SENATOR. I HILL YOU
HAVE THE FLOOR THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MISTER CHAIR FIRST I WOULD
LIKE TO START BY ACCEPTING THE
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS ON BEHALF
OF SENATOR HUESO. SB TEN FIFTY
EIGHT IS A RELIEF BILL NEEDED
TO ENSURE THE CALIFORNIANS HAVE
MEANINGFUL ACCESS TO RELIABLE
COMMUNICATIONS DURING DISASTERS
AND EMERGENCIES INCLUDING THE
ONGOING PANDEMIC. THE BILL
WOULD REQUIRE INTERNET SEARCH
THE INTERNET SERVICE PROVIDERS
ISPS TO FILE ANNUAL EMERGENCY
OPERATIONS PLANS WITH THE CPUC
AND IDENTIFIES THE BASIC
ELEMENTS THESE PLANS MUST
CONTAIN. SB TEN FIFTY EIGHT
WOULD ALSO ENSURE THAT LOW
INCOME CALIFORNIANS WHO DO NOT
HAVE ACCESS TO BROADBAND. CAN
KEEP THEIR HOME PHONE SERVICE
AT AFFORDABLE RATES THROUGH THE
LIFELINE PROGRAM. EVEN BEFORE
COVERT NINETEEN CALIFORNIANS
STRUGGLED WITH A LACK OF
BROADBAND ACCESS APPROXIMATELY
ONE THIRD OF CALIFORNIANS LACK
BROADBAND SERVICE. WELL 5% OF
CALIFORNIANS CANNOT ACCESS
BROADBAND DUE TO A LACK OF
INFRASTRUCTURE IN THEIR
COMMUNITIES NEARLY TWENTY FIVE
PERCENT. DO NOT HAVE BROADBAND
DUE TO AFFORDABILITY. I KNOW
SENATOR HUESO HAS FOUGHT HARD
FOR EXPANSION OF THESE SERVICES
IN HIS DISTRICT AS I HAVE FOR
MY COAST SIDE RESIDENTS. RECENT
EMERGENCIES INCLUDING WILDFIRES
POWER SHUT OFF IN PANDEMIC HAVE
HIGHLIGHTED THE NEED FOR
TELECOMMUNICATIONS PROVIDERS TO
HAVE EMERGENCY PLANS. BUT WE
HOPE THAT THE WORST OF UTILITY
POWER SHOT OFF AND THE PANDEMIC
ARE BEHIND US WE ARE LIKELY TO
FACE MORE CHALLENGES IN THE
FUTURE. AND WE NEED TO PREPARE
NOW TO LIMIT THE RISKS FACING
CALIFORNIANS. SB TEN FIFTY
EIGHT INSURERS WE HAVE PLANS IN
PLACE TO ENSURE THAT ALL
CALIFORNIANS CAN STAY HEALTHY
SAFE AND CONNECTED WELL WE PLAN
FOR THE FUTURE. I DO HAVE SOME
WITNESSES HERE MISTER CHAIR.
THANK YOU SENATOR HILL YOU HAVE
TO WITNESSES CHRISTINE LU AND
GINA POTTER- SOLD. MADAME
MODERATOR ARE THEY ON THE LINE.
THEIR LINES ARE OPEN SORRY MR
MODERATOR. THANK YOU. WHO WHO
WOULD LIKE TO GO FIRST. I'M
YOUR HONOR I CAN GO FIRST. YOU
GOT IT. FIVE THANK YOU EVERYONE
FOR PROVIDING TURN THE
OPPORTUNITY TO EXPRESS OUR
SUPPORT FOR SB TEN FIFTY EIGHT
TODAY THIS BILL IS NARROWLY
TAILORED YET THE NECESSARY
PUZZLE PIECE TO THE LARGER
PUBLIC POLICIES EXPRESSED BY
THE LEGISLATURE AND THE
COMMISSION TO ENSURE THAT LOW
INCOME CONSUMERS HAVE ROBUST
AND RELIABLE ACCESS TO
BROADBAND ESPECIALLY DURING
EMERGENCIES. ALL PARENTS AND
HOW IT CENTRAL TO SERVICES
TODAY AND IT IS URGENT THE BILL
OF PROPERLY URGENT- THAT THE
FUNDAMENTAL MINIMUM STANDARDS
OF THESE SERVICES FOR LOW
INCOME CONSUMERS ARE NOT LEFT
TO VOLUNTARY PUBLIC RELATIONS
STATEMENT BY THE KERRIER OTHERS
BILL IS THE NECESSARY TO PROBE
PROTECT AFFORDABILITY OF THE
MOST BASIC WIRELINE WHITE BOYS
THIS IS. BILL AWFUL WAFFLE AS
TO THE I A FEW SECTIONS IN THE
LIGHT OF THE COMMISSION CPC CAN
AND DIFFICULT FORTY IN LIGHT OF
THE LONG HISTORY DEFINING RATE
REGULATION TO NOT INCLUDE
EMERGENCY MEASURES AND OTHER
KINDS OF TERMS AND CONDITIONS
OF SERVICE QUALITY AND IN LIGHT
OF THE RECENTLY SHIFTING OF
REGULATORY AND LEGAL LANDSCAPE
RECOGNIZE STATE AUTHORITY AND
POLICE POWER OVER CENTRAL
SERVICES LIKE BEYOND. ACTUALLY
OVER THE IMPACT OF THE BILL AS
A REPORTING ARE. THIS BILL DOES
NOT. ADDITION REQUIRE. BUT
INSTEAD HOLD CARRIER THE- AND
CREATES TRANSPARENCY TO ENSURE
COOPERATION AND COMPLIANCE WITH
THE COMMISSION'S CURRENT
EFFORT. TO MEET LEGISLATIVE
DIRECTIVES WHICH THE CARRIERS
OF ACTUALLY UNIFORMLY OPPOSED
BEFORE THE COMMISSION. CAN HOLD
CARRIERS ACCOUNTABLE FOR THEIR
VERY OWN PROMISES TO BUILD
ROBUST INFRASTRUCTURE AND
PROVIDE RELIABLE AND AFFORDABLE
SERVICES. THANK YOU. HAVE AN I
FEEL TO MENTION THAT WE GET
THREE MINUTES FOR BOTH SIDES SO
OF MISS POTTER YOU HAVE A
MINUTE AND A HALF. GOOD
AFTERNOON AND THANK YOU CAN YOU
HEAR ME YES. THE FULL INTERVIEW
MY NAME IS. MY NAME IS DOCTOR
GINA POTTER I'M THE
SUPERINTENDENT OF THE SANTA
FUTURE SCHOOL DISTRICT LOCATED
IN SAN DIEGO COUNTY I'VE
PROBABLY THIRD WITHIN THE FIELD
OF EDUCATION FOR ALMOST THIRTY
YEAR ALSO ON BEHALF OF ACT OR
THE ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA
SCHOOL ADMINISTRATORS BY THIRD
CHAIR OUR STATE LEGISLATIVE
POLICY COMMITTEE OUR SCHOOL
DISTRICT STRONGLY SUPPORT
SENATE BILL CAN FIFTY EIGHT THE
DIGITAL DIVIDE RELIEF PLAN.
WHICH WOULD ENSURE AFFORDABLE
ACCESS TO BROADBAND INTERNET
DURING A DISASTER WE OFFER
SUPPORT SENATOR CONSOLIDATE
BILL ELEVEN THIRTY TO PROVIDE
HIGH CAPACITY BROADBAND NETWORK
I GET YOUR FIRST ALMOST FIVE
THOUSAND PRE SCHOOL THROUGH
EIGHTH GRADE STUDENTS OF WHICH
ABOUT THOUSAND ARE ENGLISH
LEARNERS OVER 70% OR SO. ON THE
H. OUT OF EVERY THREE
CHARACTERIZE SK HOW. DURING
SCHOOL CLOSURES WE'VE MADE
GROWING CAFFERTY THIRD TWENTY
FOUR THOUSAND MALE CHILDREN
EACH WEEK THE LAUNCHER BROKE
LAST DISTANCE LEARNINGPROGRAMS
AND TO DISTRIBUTE ALMOST TWO
THOUSAND CHROMEBOOK STUDENT
OVER THREE HUNDRED TEACHERS IN
OUR DISTRICT LAUNCH THE GOOGLE
CLASSROOM GOOGLE NEEDING
PLATFORM TO VIRTUALLY TEACH
STATED THAT CANDOR BASED
CURRICULUM IN MEANINGFUL WAYS
TO OUR STUDENTS. HOWEVER OUR
FAMILY SURVEY DATA PRIOR TO
SCHOOL CLOSURES INDICATED THAT
OVER 50% OF OUR STUDENTS DID
NOT HAVE EITHER A DIGITAL
DEVICE SUCH AS A COMPUTER OR
AND OR INTERNET ACCESS AT HOME
ABLE TO EQUITABLY ACCESS THEIR
GOOGLE CLASSROOM PORTAL VIRTUAL
TEACHING MATH AN- EQUITABLE AND-
IT. IT MANY OTHER SCHOOLS
THROUGHOUT. THAT HAVE SIMILAR
VULNERABLE DE POP SUCH AS OURS
AS HE CAN FIFTY EIGHT WILL BE
IN A NEW YES. HELLO YEAH YOU
CAN HANDLE YOU'VE GOT IT
OPPORTUNITY CALL I'M ALMOST
DONE LASTING BENEFIT. SB TEN
FIFTY EIGHT WILL USHER IN A NEW
AND CRITICALCOMPONENT A STATE
DISASTER PREPAREDNESS THAT
THIRDS ARE MOST AT RISK
POPULATIONS THAT CHILDREN AND
THEIR FAMILIES THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIA WE RESPECTFULLY URGE
YOUR SUPPORT FOR AND HE CAN
FIFTY EIGHT. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU DOCTOR POTTER. NOW WE WILL
BE TAKING TESTIMONY FROM
WITNESSES THAT. ARE EITHER
PRESENT OR ON THE PHONE WE WILL
START WITH THE GALLERY ARE
THERE ANY WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
IN THE GALLERY. SEEING NINE
GOING TO THE MICROPHONE DO WE
HAVE ANY WITNESSES IN ROOM
TWENTY FORTY. SEEING NONE
MISTER MODERATOR DO WE HAVE
ANY. INDIVIDUALS WISHING TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT ON THE LINE.
ONCE AGAIN IF YOU'D LIKE TO
QUEUE UP FOR SUPPORT PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME. ONE MOMENT WHILE THE
QUEUE UP. HAVE TO GIVE THEM
THEIR LINE NUMBERS HERE ONE
MOMENT. AND I CAN MAYBE JUST
REPEAT THE NUMBER IF IT'S NOT
ON THE SCREEN IT'S EIGHT FOUR
FOUR. TWO NINE ONE SIX THREE
SIX FOUR AND THE CODE IS. EIGHT
TWO SIX THREE SEVEN SEVEN TWO.
FOR MISTER MODERATOR ANYONE
WISHING TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT.
ONE MOMENT. OUR FIRST FOUR
SUPPORT COMES ON THE LINE ONE
SIXTY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
CHAIR MEMBERS DEREK DOLPHIN
APPELLEES CALIFORNIA CITIES IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
ONE MOMENT. ANY OTHERS. THE
NEXT COMES ON THE LINE ONE
FORTY FOR YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. AND LAY WITH
THE GREEN MONEY YOU COULD TAKE
IT IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL.
THANK YOU NEXT. WE HAVE NO
OTHERS IN Q. AT THIS TIME THANK
YOU- THAT WOULD THEN TAKE US TO
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION THERE
ARE TWO CAROLINE MCINTYRE AND
STEEP CARLSON- IF YOU'RE ON THE
LINE YOUR FREE TO START YOU GET
THREE MINUTES AND THIRTY EIGHT
SECONDS. CAROLINE MANAGED CARE
MEMBERS THAT HE. MISTER CARLSON
GO FOR AN ADULT. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS STEVE
CARLSON FOR A C. T. I. A- ON
BEHALF OF THE WORLD AND
DISTRICT- THE SUGGESTION IN THE
MAIL AND THE- SUPPORTING
WITNESSES WORK SOMEHOW OR OTHER
THE- WIRELESS INDUSTRY AND
OTHER- I GUESS PETER FALLING
DOWN ON THE JOB. SB TEN FIFTY
IT OVERLOOKS THE EXTRAORDINARY
COMMITMENTS MADE BY THE
WIRELESS INDUSTRY IN KEEPING
CALIFORNIA'S CONNECTED. DURING
THIS PANDEMIC. FORTUNATELY BUT
BELIEVE ALTHOUGH WELL ATTENDED
THE RECENT AMENDMENTS ARE
UNNECESSARY AND LARGELY
PREEMPTED BY FEDERAL LAW.
WIRELESS INDUSTRY AND OTHER
TELECOM PROVIDERS SIGNED TO
KEEP AMERICA'S CONNECTED
PLEDGE- BUT NO TERMINATION FEES
AND NO LATE FEES. EACH COMPANY
ALSO HAS PROVIDED THINGS LIKE
CREE DATA OPTIONS FOR LOW
INCOME RESIDENTS. NEARLY
EFFORTS TO PORTRAY EDUCATION
INCLUDING- SUPERINTENDENT OF
PUBLIC INSTRUCTION- THURMAN'S
DIGITAL DIVIDE TASK FORCE. ON
THE ISSUES BAD WE OPPOSE OTHER
REQUIREMENT THAT WIRELESS
CARRIERS PROVIDE SERVICE ANY
RATE DEEMED AFFORDABLE BY THE
UC THE ASSEMBLY PREEMPTED BY-
FEDERAL STATUTES SECTION THREE
THIRTY TO SEE OF THE
COMMUNICATIONS ACT. ALTHOUGH
THE. THE ANALYSIS INDICATES
THAT WILL CHANGE CARRIERS
INVOLUNTARILY PROVIDING THE
INPUT THE INFORMATION TO THE P.
UC THAT UP BY TO BE OKAY.
HOWEVER THAT'S VERY DIFFERENT
THAN HAVING A STATE STATUTE
REQUIRING AND USING EVALUATING
SUCH AFFORDABILITY. WE ALSO
OPPOSE A MANDATE TO IDENTIFY
CAPITAL EXPENDITURE PLAN.
BECAUSE OUR TRADE SECRETS-
DISCLOSED PROPRIETARY AND
COMPETITIVE INFORMATION. WHICH
ALSO WHEN VIOLATE VIOLATE YES
HE DID THE CLUES ABOUT THE
ALREADY OVER WIRELESS CARRIER
NETWORK INFRASTRUCTURE. THOSE
AND OTHER REASONS WE ASK FOR
NOBLE. THANK YOU MISTER CARLSON
IS MISS MCINTYRE ON THE LINE.
MISTER CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS
CAROLINE MCINTYRE ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA CABLE AND
TELECOMMUNICATIONS ASSOCIATION.
WE ALSO ARE OPPOSED TO BE TEN
FIFTY EIGHT THE BILL IS BASED
ON A FAULTY PREMISE THAT
BROADBAND SERVICE NEED PPV
REGULATION IN ORDER TO PERFORM
WELL. NORTH THE EXCEPTIONAL
PERFORMANCE IN BROADBAND
NETWORK IN PROVIDING BROADBAND
INTERNET SERVICE DURING THE
PANDEMIC AND WHEN THE STAY AT
HOME ORDER HAVE MORE ACTIVITY
TO GO ONLINE. BILLIONS OF
DOLLARS HAVE BEEN INVESTED IN
BROADBAND NETWORKS LIKE THE CGA
MEMBER COMPANIES WE HAD MADE-
OUR ABILITY TO SUPPORT THE
ONLINE WORKING FROM HOME AND
HEALTHCARE AND PEOPLE. ALL POP.
THIS BILL WOULD ALLOW AND STATE
RATE REGULATE OF INTER THERE
MAY. K. I. S. P.'S MAILLET
KERLEY OFF RID COSTS INTERNET
SERVICE FOR QUALIFIED LOW
INCOME FAMILIES. BILL WOULD
REQUIRE THE CPC TO DEFINE AND
AFFORDABLE CLAP OF BROADBAND
INTERNET SERVICE AND REQUIRE
AYE IF PEACE TO OPERATE FOR ANY
INDIVIDUAL DISPLAYED BY A
DISASTER OR UNDER GUIDANCE TO
STAY AT HOME DURING THE STATE
OF A STATE OR LOCAL EMERGENCY.
IN RESPONSE TO THE RECENT
HEALTH EMERGENCY IN SHELTER IN
PLACE ORDER I WOULD HAVE BEEN
REQUIRED AND DAVID BELL TO
PROVIDE BROADBAND SERVICE. TO
MOST CALIFORNIANS AND EMIGRATE
TO BE PC THING FOR THE
AFFORDABLE IF YOU COULD. LET'S
SEE DO YOU THINK HAVE
JURISDICTION THE STATE
UNIVERSAL LIFELINE PROGRAM THAT
IS DESIGNED TO ENSURE TAT ALL
CONSUMERS HAVE ACCESS TO
AFFORDABLE TELECOMMUNICATION
SERVICE. THAT PROGRAM IS
WOEFULLY UNDER SUBSCRIBE
INSTEAD OF HAVING A THREE PEAT
THE FOCUS ON PROGRAMS THAT ARE
BEING VOLUNTARILY PROVIDED BY
AYE PETE. BUT SHOULD BE FOCUSED
ON DETERMINING HOW TO IMPROVE
UPON THE LIFELINE PROGRAM TO
INCREASE THE NUMBER OF CONSUMER
THAT ENTERTAINMENT BENEFITS
THAT THANK YOU WELL ACTUALLY I
JUST LIKE TO ADD THAT MARKET
ENTRY PROGRAM MISSION HAD BEEN
INCLUDED IN THE BILL ALSO. INTO
ELIMINATE COMMUNICATION SERVICE
OPTION FOR CONSUMERS BY
THREATENING TO WITHDRAW THANKS
LYNN HOLD AFTER READING THAT
STORY FOR AYE IF HE PRETTY
THREE THIRDS WEAVER CLASS OR
NOT. THANK YOU MS MCINTYRE.
THAT TAKES US TO WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION IN THE GALLERY. YES
WE HAVE A WITNESS. YES MISTER
CHAIR MEMBERS CHRIS FOR KAYLEE
ON BEHALF OF THE COMPUTING
TECHNOLOGY INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION
AND RESPECTFUL OPPOSITION THANK
YOU THANK YOU MISTER KAYLEE ANY
OTHER WITNESSES IN THE GALLERY.
SOME OF THE MOVING ARE YOU
GOING TO SPEAK NO THANK YOU
OKAY I. ARE THERE ANY WITNESSES
IN TWENTY FORTY NOTE THAT TAKES
US TO THE PHONE LINE MISTER
MODERATOR. AND IF YOU'D LIKE
TO- QUEUE UP AND SUPPORT PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO. IN OPPOSITION.
A PARDON ME IN OPPOSITION. ONCE
AGAIN PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO. WE
DO HAVE A FEW KILLING UP ONE
MOMENT WHEN THEY GET THEIR LINE
NUMBERS THANK YOU. WHENEVER
YOU'RE READY MISTER MODERATOR.
THEY DON'T KNOW THEIR LINE
NUMBERS IT'LL JUST BE A MOMENT
ALRIGHT THANK YOU.
OUR FIRST
LINE IS A LINE OF ONE SEVEN
THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. ON BEHALF OF FRONTIER
COMMUNICATIONS I RESPECTFULLY
IN OPPOSITION TO THE BILL.
THANK YOU. NEXT. MINE ONE SIXTY
FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. THANK YOU THIS IS PAM
LIMITS ON BEHALF OF
CONSOLIDATED COMMUNICATIONS AND
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL. THANK
YOU. ANY OTHER WITNESSES MISTER
MODERATOR. YES OUR NEXT IS LINE
ONE EIGHTY ONE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES GOOD
AFTERNOON SHARE- MEMBERS ALONG
DEPENDING ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA COMMUNICATIONS
ASSOCIATION IN OPPOSITION TO AT
TEN FIFTY EIGHT THANK YOU. IF
YOU. NEXT FOR GOING TO THE LINE
OF ONE SIXTY TO YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS
CORPS IN JENSEN WITH TECH NET
IN OPPOSITION THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. NEXT WE'RE GONNA GO TO THE
LINE OF ONE SEVENTY FOR YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD
THANK YOU MELANIE FIGUEROA ON
BEHALF OF THE RISE IN IN
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU. OUR NEXT
LINE IS NINE ONE EIGHTY TWO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI THIS IS
WHAT MAMA FROM THE CALIFORNIA
CHAMBER OF COMMERCE AND
RESPECTFUL OPPOSITION THAT HAS
TO BE TEN FIFTY EIGHT. THANK
YOU. AND WE HAVE NO FURTHER AND
Q. THANK YOU MISTER MODERATOR
THAT TAKES IS NOW TO MY
COLLEAGUES DOES ANYONE WISH TO
ASK THE- CENTER ANY QUESTIONS
ON THE BILL. IN A REVIEW. THANK
YOU AT CAN YOU PLEASE AND I'M
SORRY I DON'T KNOW IF YOUR-
QUIPTEL AT ADDRESS THIS
QUESTION BUT SOMEONE AND ONE OF
THE CALLS MENTION- VIOLATION OF
TRADE SECRETS SUCH AS WANT TO
SEE IF SOMEONE CAN CLARIFY THAT
FOR ME. IS THERE ANYWAY I AM
VERY GOAL IS THERE ANY WAY THAT
SOMEONE CAN ADDRESS OUT WHAT
THE I THINK I HEARD OVER THE
LIFE ON THE LINE- A VIOLATION
OF TRADE SECRETS CAN SOMEONE
ADDRESS I JUST TO. CLARIFY THAT
COMMENT. THIS IS. ARE YOU
LOOKING FOR THE SUPPORTER OF
THE COMMENT OR A NOT A RESPONSE
TO THE COMMENT. IN OPPOSITION
MENTIONED THAT THAT SOMEHOW IT
VIOLATES TRADE SECRETS AND I
JUST WANT SOMEONE- THAT CAN
SPEAK TO THE BILL AND HOW THIS.
MAY BE THE CASE OR NOT IF THEY
CAN CLARIFY THAT FOR ME THANK
YOU. THE BIGGER PERHAPS THE
DOCTOR POTTER COULD INSURE. AT
ACTUALLY THIS IS CHRISTINE MAY
YOU FROM TURN I MAYBE ONLY
BECAUSE IT IT THE ISSUE IS
PREVENTING THE DATA IN FRONT OF
THE COMMISSION. AND CARRIERS
ARE ROUTINELY CONCERNED AND I
AND I UNDERSTAND THE CONCERN
ABOUT PRESENTING- PROPRIETARY
INFORMATION. TO THE COMMISSION
AND OR POTENTIALLY TO THE
PUBLIC AND INVESTMENT DATA CAN
BE QUITE SENSITIVE AND SO THERE
WOULD JUST NEED TO BE AWAY AND
THERE IS PLENTY OF WAYS FOR THE
COMMISSION. TO PROTECT THAT
INVESTMENT INFORMATION OF THE
CARRIERS ARE CONCERNED ABOUT
PRESENTING BUT THE COMMISSION
NEEDS THE INVESTMENT
INFORMATION UNDERSTAND THE
FUTURE OF BROADBAND THE
CALIFORNIA- WE TURN SUGGEST
THAT DOES NOT TRADE TO GET
VIOLATION IS A SOMETHING THAT
THE COMMISSION WOULD NEED TO
PROTECT THE DATA AS IT. BEING
PRESENTED. THANK YOU TOM AND I
HAVE ONE MORE QUESTION. AND
IT'S MY UNDERSTANDING- SENATOR
RUBIO THAT THERE IS NO
VIOLATION OF- IT'LL- SO THANK
YOU FOR THAT CLARIFICATION- I
THINK I ALSO HEARD ANOTHER
SPEAKER DISCUSS- THE LIFELINE
PROGRAM AND HOW IT'S UNDER
UTILIZED THESE ARE PROGRAMS
THAT ARE SET UP TO. TO HELP
PEOPLE OF FIVE SOMEONE CAN
SPEAK TO- HELD THIS WOULD BE
DIFFERENT AND BE USED IN A MUCH
MORE EFFICIENT WAY VERSUS THE
UNDER UTILIZED LIFELINE PROGRAM
THAT THEY- I THAT THE
OPPOSITION MENTIONED. I
COULDN'T REALLY HEAR THE
QUESTION I'M SORRY SENATOR
RUBIO IF THE MICROPHONE IS
THERE ENOUGH THANK YOU ASKED
SOMEONE IN THE LIGHT MENTION
AND I THINK IT WAS ON THE
OPPOSITION SIDE THE MENTION
THAT THERE'S A LIFELINE PROGRAM
DESIGNED TO HELP ALREADY BUT
THAT'S UNDER UTILIZED- IF THERE
IS ANY WAY TO JUST MAKE THAT
DISTINCTION THIS WILL HELP THAT
MANY MORE PEOPLE. I THINK THAT
WOULD HELP MORE PEOPLE WOULD
WOULD NOT INCREASE THE- THE
ACCESS THAT'S NECESSARY THAT WE
WERE LOOKING FOR ITS THE
AFFORDABILITY ASPECT OF IT. AS
WELL AS THE BROADBAND ACCESS
THAT NEEDS TO BE ADDRESSED FOR
THIS BILL BECAUSE- BOTH OF
THOSE- WITHIN IT SO. I MEAN
CERTAINLY MORE PEOPLE USING
LIFELINE IS ONE THING BUT-
THAT'S NOT GOING TO ENCOURAGE
OR HELP THE ISSUE OF BROADBAND
ACCESS TO THOSE COMMUNITIES
THAT HAVE NOT HAD IT AND DON'T
HAVE IT TODAY. THANK YOU FOR A
FOR THAT CLARIFICATION AND ALSO
I DID WANT TO MENTION ON THE
OTHER PART THAT THE BILL DOES.
OUR PUBLIC REPORTING OF
CONFIDENTIAL INFORMATION FOR
THAT ON THE ISSUE. THANK
SENATOR. WELL I HAVE A WITNESS
UP IN THE GALLERY I'M NOT SURE
IF HE WANTS TO. JUST GIVE HIS
NAME AND AFFILIATION AND
POSITION OR IF HE WANTS TO.
RESPOND TO THE SENATOR US AND
RUBIO QUESTION. I. IS THE MY
PLAN IN THE GALLERY. IDENTIFY
YOURSELF. SENATOR OF BURNING A
RUST WITH THE COMPANY CABLE AND
TELECOMMUNICATIONS ASSOCIATION
TO THE TWO ISSUES I WAS
PROPOSING TO HAVE A RESPONSE.
THAT IS FINE WITH ME THAT'S
FINE WITH THE PRISONER SO TO
THE ISSUE OF TRADE SECRETS ARE
CONFIDENTIALITY. BOB AND
INDUSTRY IS A VERY COMPETITIVE
<c.magenta>ARKET SO THE I REPRESENT</c>
COMCAST CHARTER **** AMONG
OTHER COMPANIES SO WE HAVE IN
COMPETITION WITH FRONTIER
EIGHTEEN T. SO TO THE EXTENT OF
THIS INFORMATION IS SHARED.
WITH OTHER ENTITIES ITS HIGHLY
CONFIDENTIAL AND IS THAT THAT
IS OUR CONCERN AT THIS IS A
TRADE SECRETS OF TRACY PERCENT
OF THE PUBLIC RECORDS ACT AS A
HIGHLY CONFIDENTIAL SOURCE OF
INFORMATION. AND TO THE ISSUE
BROADBAND DEPLOYMENT UNDER
UTILIZATION OF BROADBAND.
LEGISLATION RECENTLY IN THE
PAST HAS HAS PROPOSED THAT THE
PC OPEN A PROCEEDING TO LOOK AT
OF MODIFYING LIFELINE PROGRAM
SO THAT HE CAN EXTEND BROADBAND
SERVICES THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
HAS A RIGHT. DOESN'T MEAN FOR
WORK. SENATOR HAS SOMEONE IN
THE PAST THAT LOOKS AT THE X.
OF LIFELINE TO INCLUDE
BROADBAND SERVICES I JUST WANT
TO SHARE THAT INFORMATION THANK
YOU. THANK YOU MISTER OSCO I
COULD NOT IDENTIFY YOU. FROM
THIS DISTANCE SO I APOLOGIZE.
ANY OTHER. FROM MEMBERS OF THE
QUE YEAH SENATOR BRADFORD
PLEASE THANK YOU MISTER VICE
CHAIR I DON'T HAVE A QUESTION
IS A COMMON AND JUST TO PIGGY
BACK ON WHAT MISTER ROSS ROSS
STATED- BASED ON MY EXPERIENCE
OF WORKING WITH LOW INCOME-
TELECOM IT BROAD BASE- ISSUES I
APPRECIATE. THE AUTHOR'S WORK-
HERE BUT I DO HAVE SOME
CONCERNS IT SEEMS TO ME THE
BILL IS FOCUSED PRIMARILY ON
INTERNET PORTABILITY ISSUES
FIRST INTERNET SERVICE
PROVIDERS DESERVES SOME CREDIT
FOR PROVIDING LOW INCOME
PROGRAMS WITHOUT CAPS ON THEIR
PARTICIPANTS. BUT THIS IS NOT
SUFFICIENT ON ITS OWN THESE
PROGRAMS NEED TO BE ASSESSABLE
IT IS OFTEN UNCLEAR WHETHER
HOUSEHOLD OUT SIR PART WHERE
EACH PROGRAMS OR CHOOSE TO
PARTICIPATE SO I THINK ARE MORE
INFORMATION NEEDED BUT THE LACK
OF CLARITY ON ITS OWN. IS CALLS
FOR CONCERNS ME SECOND THERE'S
A LEGITIMATE DEBATE ABOUT HOW
FAR IS TOO FAR WHEN IT COMES TO
RATES OF STERN SERVICE PROGRAMS
THIS REQUIRES. IDENTIFICATION
OF AFFORDABLE CLASS OF SERVICE
AS DEFINED BY THE P. C. P. YOU
SEE. I UNDERSTAND OPPOSITION
HAS CONCERT. THIS GOES TOO FAR
WHEN A COMBINED WITH PROVISIONS
ABOUT NOT RENEWING FRANCHISES
SUCH AS DEBORAH AND OUR LICENSE
AND SI PC AND- BUT I THINK
THERE IS. HERE PINE I'M
PROMOTE. THE PRO GOAL OF.
SHOULD BE ENSURE BUT AFFORDABLE
SERVER PLANTS ARE ACCEPTABLE TO
CUSTOMERS AND I TOTALLY SUPPORT
THOSE GOALS AND OBJECTIVES I
DON'T THINK WE NEED TO GO
FURTHER. AT OUR RATE READ. OF
INTERNET SERVICES TO THE C. C.
P. YOU SEE HOW MANY JOBS THAT
THEY HAVE ALREADY AND I MANY
TIMES- FELL INTO COMPLETE
THOSE. AND FINALLY I AGREE THAT
LIFELINE PROGRAM SHOULD BE
PROTECTED AND PROBABLY EXPANDED
TO INCLUDE BROADBAND IN FACT I
A BILL LAST YEAR THAT WOULD
HAVE STARTED THIS PROCESS. THE
FCC HAS FAILED WITH THE
DELIVERY OF THESE TRANSITION
TOWARD BROADBAND BASS LIFELINE
SERVICES. THEY SHOULD HAVE BEEN
DONE ON. THE AVERAGE SHOULD SAY
THEY SHOULD HAVE BEEN DONE SO
IN A THOUGHTFUL MANNER THAT
PROTECTED LEGACY WIRELINE
CUSTOMERS WHO WANT TO KEEP
THEIR PHONE LINES. THIS BILL
ARE PROPERLY PROTECTS THOSE
CUSTOMERS EVEN WHEN THE FED TO
FILL TO SO I HOPE TO CHEER WILL
CONTINUE HIS WORK ON THIS ISSUE
AS THE BOOK BILL MOVES FORWARD
AND I'M HAVE TO SUPPORT THE DAY.
THANK YOU SENATOR BRADFORD. ANY
OTHER COLLEAGUES WISHING TO
SPEAK. OF THEN- I DO HAVE ONE
QUESTION SENATOR HILL AND THAT
IS THIS SEEMS AT- TO BE OF THE
DOMAIN OR JURISDICTION OF THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT. AND I I'M
JUST WONDERING WHY ONE STATE
WOULD WANT TO. DO SOMETHING
UNIQUE ON ITS OWN. WHEN IT'S
ALREADY BEING TAKEN CARE OF.
YES EIGHT SEVEN. YOU KNOW I
EIGHT IT'S IN THANK YOU FOR THE
QUESTION SENATOR MORE LIKE A
YOU KNOW I BELIEVE FROM WHAT
WE'VE READ THE RECENT FEDERAL
COURT DECISIONS MAKE IT CLEAR
THAT THE FCC DOES NOT HAVE
BLANKET PREEMPTION AUTHORITY%
ESPECIALLY WHEN THE FCC HAS
DECLINED TO SET RULES ON I. S.
P.'S REGARDING THIS PARTICULAR
ISSUE. SO THEY MAY HAVE
CERTAINLY PREEMPTION ON OTHER
ISSUES AND AREAS THAT WE'VE
HAD. CONVERSATIONS UP OVER THE
YEARS ON- BUT ON THIS
PARTICULAR ISSUE WE DON'T
BELIEVE IT DOES. THANK YOU. A
HEARING NO FURTHER QUESTIONS
SENATOR HILL PLEASE GIVE US
YOUR CLOSING COMMENTS THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MISTER CHAIR AND- I
AM PROUD TO ADD MY NAME IS A CO
AUTHOR TO THIS MEASURE BY
SENATOR HUESO AND THE
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR RIVAL
COLLEGE. THANK YOU MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
SB TEN FIFTY EIGHT BY SENATOR
WESSEL TO PASS TO BE AMENDED TO
PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS. SENATOR HILL.
BY HILL ON MORELAND NO MORE
LIKE NO. BRADFORD ALL RIGHT
BRADFORD I CHIANG NO CHIANG
THEM. DOLLY NO TELLING THEM
DODD. DODD I. HERTZBERG MCGUIRE.
PAN HI CAN I RUBIO HI RUBIO I.
SKINNER BY SKINNER I STERN HI
EARN I. WIENER AYE WIENER I.
THE DATA UP TO EIGHT DAYS AND
THREE KNOWS PASSES A THREE AND
WILL KEEP THE ROLE OPEN FOR OUR
ABSENT MEMBERS THANK YOU VERY
MUCH SENATOR HILL THANK YOU
MISTER GRAVEL YOURS GOOD WORK
TODAY AND WELCOME SENATOR
JACKSON'S- YOU MAY PRESENT YOUR
YOUR BILL SB TEN SIXTY NINE
PLEASE THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. I'M OF LOOKING AT THIS OF
A NEW ONE UNLIKE ANY I IN THE
PERSPECTIVE ANY OTHER
PERSPECTIVE OF FOURTEEN YEARS
IN THE LEGISLATURE SO HI YA I
HAVE TO SAY THIS IS A QUITE AN
INTERESTING CHALLENGE. BUT I DO
APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
BRING THIS BILL FORWARD AND I
FIRST WANT TO START BY THANKING
THE COMMITTEE STAFF OF FOR THIS
FOR TO EXCELLENT ANALYSIS AND
ASSISTANCE- THE- THE BILL AS
AMENDED THE AMENDMENTS OF WHICH
I. AM ENTHUSIASTICALLY WILL
TAKING I THINK REALLY CLARIFY
THIS BILL AND- PROVIDED AN
OPPORTUNITY TO SERVE THE
PURPOSE FOR WHICH IT IS
INTENDED. FOR THIS BILL
REQUIRES TELECOMMUNICATIONS
SERVICE PROVIDERS TO REPORT AN
INVENTORY OF ITS CRITICAL
INFRASTRUCTURE. S. DEFINED BY
THE CALIFORNIA PUBLIC UTILITIES
COMMISSION. ON AN ANNUAL BASIS
TO LOCAL EMERGENCY MANAGEMENT
OFFICIALS WITH REAL TIME
UPDATES DURING EMERGENCIES AND
PUBLIC SAFETY POWER SHUTDOWN
EVENTS. IT ALSO REQUIRES THE
TELESCOPE WAS. TO MAKE
AVAILABLE IN EMERGENCY
OPERATIONS TRAINED OFFICIAL ONE
AND HE- SEE AN EMERGENCY
OPERATIONS CENTER IS SET UP.
AND FINALLY IT REQUIRES THAT
THEY SURE WITH THE CPUC
WHATEVER INFORMATION THEY HAVE
ABOUT HOW THEIR NETWORKS
PERFORMED WHEN EMERGENCY
NOTIFICATIONS ARE SENT BY
EMERGENCY MANAGERS AND
SOMETIMES NEVER RECEIVED BY THE
PUBLIC. SO THIS BILL A CAME AS
A RESULT OF A NUMBER OF THE
TRAGEDIES THAT WE HAVE
EXPERIENCED HERE IN CALIFORNIA
AT THE TIME I WAS CHAIRING THE
JOINT COMMITTEE ON EMERGENCY
MANAGEMENT WE TRUST THE HAD THE
CAMP EXCUSE ME THE- FIRES IN
CINEMA AND THE CAR FIRE- THE I
KNOW SENATOR DODD EXPERIENCED-
VERY INTENSELY- WHEN THE
CAMPFIRE. DEVASTATED PARADISE
CALIFORNIA TWENTY EIGHTEEN
SIXTY SIX TELECOMMUNICATIONS
FACILITIES WERE DESTROYED OR
OUT OF SERVICE LEAVING BOTH
RESIDENTS AND EMERGENCY
RESPONDERS ON ABLE TO
COMMUNICATE WITH EACH OTHER.
THIS MAKES A DISASTER EVEN MORE
A DISASTER WHEN YOU CANNOT FIND
OUT WHAT IS GOING ON. THIS
PROBLEM WAS THIRTEEN TIMES
WORSE. DURING THE SONOMA COUNTY
KINCAID FIRE WHICH SHUT DOWN
EIGHT HUNDRED AND SEVENTY FOUR
TOWERS IN OCTOBER OF TWENTY
NINETEEN. ALSO IN THE FALL OF
TWENTY NINETEEN P. GENIES PS PS
VANCE RESULTED IN NEARLY HALF A
MILLION BAY AREA RESIDENTS
GOING WITHOUT SHALL VOICE OR
INTERNET SERVICES DURING HIGH
FIRE DANGER WHETHER. THAT MEANT
A HUNDRED AND SIXTY SHELLS DOWN
IN MARIN COUNTY SENATOR
REQUIRES DISTRICT A HUNDRED
EIGHTEEN IN SONOMA COUNTY
SENATOR MCGUIRE AND SENATOR
DODGE DISTRICT A HUNDRED AND
EIGHTY FOUR DOWN AND COST A
CONTRA COSTA COUNTY SENATOR
DODGE DISTRICT. NINETY SIX IN
SAN MATEO COUNTY SENATOR HILL
AND SENATOR WINNERS DISTRICT
AND ANOTHER EIGHTY NINE IN THE
SANTA CLARA COUNTY AREA SENATOR
HILLS DISTRICT AND TOP IT OFF
WITH TWENTY FIVE MORE IN NAPA
COUNTY SO THAT SENATOR DODD.
WAS SUFFERING A CUTE. SO I.
THESE WERE DOWN NOW WHILE OF MY
COLLEAGUES. OUR INCLUDING THOSE
OF YOU HERE TODAY HAVE
SUCCESSFULLY PUSHED. FOR AND
SOME HAVE PASSED IMPORTANT
LEGISLATION TO REQUIRE FASTER
OUTAGE REPORTING AN INCREASE
BACKUP POWER BY INVESTOR OWNED
UTILITIES AND
TELECOMMUNICATIONS SERVICE
PRIVATE PROVIDERS THIS BILL IS
FOCUSED ON IMPROVING
INFORMATION SHARING FROM TELCOS
TO EMERGENCY MANAGERS IN THREE
FUNDAMENTAL WAYS FIRSTLY
REQUIRES TELECOM SERVICE
PROVIDERS TO REPORT THE
LOCATION OF THEIR CRITICAL
INFRASTRUCTURE ON AN ANNUAL
BASIS. AN OPERATING STATUS OF
THAT INFRASTRUCTURE IN AS CLOSE
TO REAL TIME AS POSSIBLE DURING
CRISIS WHY WELL IF THESE IF
THESE WARNING FACILITIES GO
DOWN. THEN THE LAW ENFORCEMENT
AGENCIES WHICH ARE RESPONSIBLE
FOR NOTIFYING PEOPLE KNOW THAT
THEY'VE GOT TO TAKE OTHER STEPS.
THE INFORMATION ISN'T COP ISN'T
BEING. COMMUNICATED BECAUSE
THESE FACILITIES ARE DOWN SO
THAT GIVES THEM THE OPPORTUNITY
TO THE LITERALLY AND I'VE SEEN
THIS HAPPEN IN MY OWN BACK DOOR.
ALL LAW ENFORCEMENT OFFICERS
COMING DOOR TO DOOR TO DOOR TO
TELL PEOPLE THEY NEED TO LEAVE.
AND IT'S BECAUSE THEY HAVE THIS
INFORMATION THAT THEY ARE ABLE
TO LITERALLY PUT THESE BOOTS ON
THE GROUND AND SAVE LIVES. THIS
EMERGENCY THIS BILL ALSO GIVES
EMERGENCY MANAGEMENT OFFICIALS
THE INFORMATION THEY NEED TO
KNOW TO BOTH PLAN AHEAD AND TO
RESPOND QUICKLY TO THESE
EMERGENCIES SO ARE THIS IS
CRITICALLY IMPORTANT TO GIVE
THE FIRES UP WERE THOSE TOWERS
ARE THEN IT IS REASONABLE FOR
LAW ENFORCEMENT TO ASSUME THEY
ARE GOING TO HAVE TO HAVE A
BACKUP PLAN. AND HOPEFULLY THEY
WILL DEVELOP ONCE THEY KNOW
WHERE THESE VARIOUS FACILITIES
ARE I MIGHT MENTION THAT WE
ALSO HAVE A HOPEFULLY ADDRESS
THE CONCERNS THAT THESE ARE.
OUR TRADE SECRETS OR THAT THERE
IS SECURITY CONCERNS BECAUSE
WE'VE ADDRESSED THAT AND SAID
THAT THE INFORMATION WILL
CONTINUE TO BE SUBJECT TO THE
CYBERSECURITY ANOTHER
REGULATIONS THAT EXIST BUT THAT
THE INFORMATION WILL BE MADE
AVAILABLE TO LAW ENFORCEMENT
BECAUSE THE ONES THAT NEED TO
KNOW. IN ORDER SECOND SAVE
LIVES SECONDLY. BILL TELCO TO
PROVIDE TO EMERGENCY MANAGEMENT
OFFICIALS THE CONTACT
INFORMATION FOR A RELEVANT LEE
TRAIN TELCO OFFICIALS WHO CAN
BE REACHED TELEPHONICALLY ARE
ASKED TO JOIN THEM. IN THE
EMERGENCY OPERATIONS MAN'S.
HAVING HAVING SEEN THIS
FIRSTHAND AS MANY OF YOU HAVE
WHEN YOU WERE IN THAT COMMAND
CENTER TOGETHER IT IS AN
OPPORTUNITY TO SHARE
INFORMATION AND TO LEARN WHAT'S
GOING ON THAT YOU WILL NOT KNOW
OTHERWISE. THE TELCOS HAVE
REFUSED TO PARTICIPATE IN THESE
PROGRAMS AND WE NEED TO KNOW WE
NEED THEIR EXPERTISE IN THAT
COMMAND CENTER IN REAL TIME
WHEN THESE EVENTS ARE OCCURRING
AND THIRDLY THIS MEASURE
REQUIRES THE TELCOS TO HELP US
UNDERSTAND WHETHER EMERGENCY
NOTIFICATIONS ARE GOING THROUGH
THEIR NETWORKS. SINCE WE'VE
SEEN ALL TOO DEVASTATINGLY.
WHEN THE SCRIPT DON'T GO
THROUGH DUE TO WIN OUTAGE OF
DAMAGED EQUIPMENT THE PEOPLE
ARE NOT GIVEN THOSE WARNINGS
AND I CAN TELL YOU THAT THERE
ARE PEOPLE AND BLOCKED AID THAT
GET THE NOTICE AND PEOPLE IN
BLOCK B. THE DON'T. AND WE NEED
TO KNOW WHY AND WHEN AND THAT
IS THE THIRD PART OF THIS BILL
AND AGAIN- THIS IS A BATTERY
SAVING LIVES. WE WORKED WITH.
THE OPPOSITION. I THINK THE AS
I MENTIONED AMENDMENTS I THINK
ARE ARE EXCELLENT AND WILL HELP
US GET TO THIS POINT- AGAIN WE
REALLY DO NEED TO- MAKE SURE
THAT WHEN THESE URGENCY IS
HAPPENED WHEN PSP ESSES OCCUR.
THAT WE ARE ON THE BALL AND
THAT WE CAN ADDRESS THE
PROBLEMS AS QUICKLY AS POSSIBLE
I NEED THE CAR TO BE A PARTNER
AT BEST THAT'S WHAT THIS DOES
AND WE THAT I WOULD RISK. I FOR
YOUR VOTE. THANK YOU SIR CHECK.
DUE TO THE CONSTRAINTS
REGARDING THE LENGTH OF
HEARINGS THE TECHNOLOGY
CONSIDERATIONS- WE WILL
INSTITUTE TIME LIMITS ON
TESTIMONY. ACCORDINGLY EACH
SIDE WILL ONLY BE PERMITTED A
TOTAL OF THREE MINUTES. AND
THEN ALL THOSE WISHING TO
TESTIFY AS SUPPORTERS. MUST
LIMIT THEIR COMMENTS TO THEIR
NAME AFFILIATION AND POSITION
ON THE MEASURE I UNDERSTAND
SENATOR JACKSON GOT TWO
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT. THAT IS
CORRECT PATRICK MADE ART AND-
UNIVERSE OF MOON DOES- IF-
MISTER MINARD IS- ON THE LINE
PLEASE BEGIN. AND NOT HEARING
MISTER MAYNARD WILL GO TO
MISTER. UNIVERSE MOONDANCE. IF
YOU ARE ON HE LINE PLEASE
PROCEED WITH YOUR TESTIMONY. I
THINK THERE MIGHT HAVE BEEN A
MIX UP HERE BUT I CAN TELL YOU
MISTER MAYNARD IS FROM THE
VENTURA COUNTY SHERIFF'S OFFICE
OF EMERGENCY SERVICES ARE MORE
CLOSELY WITH HIM ON THIS
MEASURE- TO MAKE SURE THAT- WE
ADDRESS THE CONCERNS THAT THEY
THAT THEY HAVE EXPERIENCE
DURING THE NUMEROUS WILDFIRES.
THAT OF INTER COUNTY AND MY
COLLEAGUE SENATOR STERN AND I
HAVE EXPERIENCED IT FAR TO
GREAT LENGTH AND MISTER MUNEER
ROSE. UP FROM THE SANTA BARBARA
COUNTY OFFICE OF EMERGENCY
MANAGEMENT AGAIN. ANOTHER
GENTLEMAN WITH WHOM WE'VE
WORKED VERY CLOSELY TO TRY TO
GET THIS BILL RIGHT SO THAT WE
CAN PROTECT THE PUBLIC IN REAL
TIME PLAN FOR FUTURE
EMERGENCIES MAKE SURE THAT WHEN
WE HAVE THIS P. S. P. IS AND
I'M TOLD THAT. THE GENIE IS NOT
GONNA BE ABLE TO MEET ITS-
THIRTY THREE PERCENT. OF
NEED TO MAKE SURE THAT PEOPLE
ARE AWARE OF THESE THINGS THAT
WE HAVE THE SUPPORT OF OUR
TELECOMS. AND MY APOLOGIES THAT
THEY ARE WITHIN A. B. WE WILL
OF WAITED TO GO TO THE- OTHERS
THAT ARE IN SUPPORT OF SB TEN
SIXTY NINE AND WE WILL GO BACK
TO YOUR WITNESSES TO SEE IF
THEY- TO APPEAR IN THE- AS SOON
AS A- SEVEN OPEN MIND AT THIS
TIME YOU COULD GO. THANK YOU
PLEASE PROCEED. HI I'M SORRY
DIFFERENT CHECKING HER ME. YES
YES WE CAN SORRY I MISSED CHAIR
AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS THE
THROUGH THE INNER SCREEN BUT
THE SANTA BARBARA COUNTY OFFICE
OF EMERGENCY MANAGEMENT I'M A
GAL-I WOULD LIKE TO THINK HE
THE COMMITTEE FOR HEARING MY
TESTIMONY TODAY ON THIS
IMPORTANT ISSUE ONE OF THEM A
LOT OF OUR OFFICE IS. JUNE YOU.
THE BILL TO LEARN AND REACH
READ THE FOR AN- IN ONE OF THEM
CRITICAL OUT. OF OUR WORK. I
WHICH MEANS WE CURRENTLY LOOK
FOR OPPORTUNITIES TO IMPROVE
ALERT AND WARNING PART OF
CALLED IN PROPHECY. SB TEN
SIXTY NINE WILL PROVIDE
INFORMATION ON THE EFFICACY OF
EMERGENCY ALERT. THAT ARE
TRANSMITTED THROUGH THE
TELECOMMUNICATIONS
INFRASTRUCTURE IN REAL TIME.
THIS IS ESPECIALLY IMPORTANT IN
THE EVENT OF A MESSAGE. AS A
RESULT IN ISSUES OR DISASTER
RELATED IMPACTED CELL TOWERS OR
OTHER TELECOMMUNICATIONS
INFRASTRUCTURE. EIGHT
FOUNDATION FOR. LOW PUBLIC
SAFETY OFFICIALS LIKE MYSELF
CAN ACT QUICKLY AND
CONFIDENTLY. AND INITIATE ANY
PROTECTIVE ACTION TO ENSURE THE
COMMUNITY IS PROPRLY INFORMED.
ON THE NOTED IMPACT- KEEP
PRINCIPLE OF EMERGENCY
MANAGEMENT IS A COMPREHENSIVE
ACCOUNTING OF ALL POTENTIAL
IMPACT. INCLUDING IMPACTED
CRITICAL INFRASTRUCTURE. OUR
OFFICE MAINTAINS A LIST OF
CRITICAL INFRASTRUCTURE AND HE
RESOURCES WITHIN THE COUNTY IN
VARIOUS FACTORS AND THAT
INCLUDES GOVERNMENT HEALTHCARE
ENERGY AND COMMUNICATION. THIS
IS AN EFFORT THAT WE DIDN'T
REINVIGORATED THE LAST YEAR
BECAUSE OF THE THREAT POSED BY
PUBLIC SAFETY PARTIAL AFTER PF
YES. I WITH OUR OFFICE HOLDING
INFORMATION SESSIONS WITH
VARIOUS TELECOMMUNICATIONS
PROVIDERS IN THE COUNTY SO THAT
WE CAN LEARN MORE ABOUT THEIR
ABILITY TO BUILD RESILIENCE AND
THEIR INFRASTRUCTURE NETWORK
AND HOW THEY WOULD EXPECT THEIR
INFRASTRUCTURE WHICH THERE
DURING A PF PIA. SO HAVING THE
LOCATION THAT IS THE GUILD
COMMUNICATION IN A CRITICAL
INFRASTRUCTURE REALLY HELPED
EMERGENCY MANAGERS COMPOSED A
MORE COMPLETE AND ACCURATE
PICTURE OF WHAT COULD BE
IMPACTED BY AN ARRAY OF
DISASTERS AND INCORPORATE THIS
INFORMATION INTO EMERGENCY.
PLANNING LOCALLY. THANK YOU
MUCH FOR THE- INDUSTRY IS STILL
NOT ON THE LINE SO WE WANNA GO
TO OTHER WITNESSES OR IF
SUPPORTERS WHO ARE HERE IN THE
GALLERY OF THE SENATE CHAMBERS.
SEEING NO ONE DO WE HAVE ANYONE
IN ROOM TWENTY FORTY SEE NO ONE
FERRET SO THANK YOU WE WILL NOW
MOVE ON TO WITNESSES WAITING TO
TESTIFY VIA THE TELECONFERENCE
RIVERS. MODERATOR IF YOU WOULD
PLEASE PROP THE INDIVIDUALS
WAITING TO TESTIFY ON SB TEN
SIXTY NINE PLEASE. THIS IS FOR
SUPPORT SO PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO FOUR SUPPORT. OUR FIRST
LINE IS LINE ONE NINETY ONE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. YEAH NOT YOUR
HERNANDEZ ON BEHALF OF TURN IN
SUPPORT OF BILL. THANK YOU
MISTER HERNANDEZ. WE DO HAVE A
FEW MORE THEIR CUED UP ON. NEXT
WE WILL GO TO THE LINE SEVENTY
YOUR LINE IS OPEN CALL AHEAD.
HELLO HI THIS IS SEAN TO CATCH-
A BLOCK PLANE ACCESS HUMBLE IN
EUREKA AND SUPPORT THE MEASURE.
VERY GOOD THANK YOU. NEXT
SUPPORTER. ONE MOMENT. THE NEXT
SUPPORTERS LINE ONE SEVENTY SIX
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HELLO MY
NAME IS BRIAN HOLLANDER ON FROM
INDEPENDENT LIVING RESOURCE
CENTER OF THE TRI COUNTIES IN
SUPPORT OF. AND SIXTY NINE.
THANK YOU. AND WE HAVE ONE MORE
HERE'S JUST ONE MOMENT WHERE
THEY GET THEIR LINE NUMBER. AND
THE OKAY ONE MOMENT THEY'RE NOT
IN YOUR MIND ONE EIGHTY SEVEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. LITERATURE NUMBERS
CRISTINA GALLAGHER ON BEHALF OF
THE COUNTY OF SANTA BARBARA AND
SUPPORT SB TEN SIXTY NINE THANK
YOUNG. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TESTIMONY. AND THAT WAS OUR
LAST ONE IN Q. VERY GOOD THANK
YOU A MODERATE COULD YOU PLEASE
CHECK THE LINE ONCE AGAIN JUST
TO MAKE SURE WE'VE HEARD FROM
ALL OF THE SUPPORT WITNESSES
FOR. ARTS SUPPORTERS OF SB TEN
SIXTY NINE. ONCE AGAIN IF YOU
WOULD LIKE TO BE- IN Q. FOUR
SUPPORT IT'S ONE ZERO. WE DO
NOT HAVE ANYONE QUEUING UP AT
THIS TIME THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MODERATE OR NOT WE WILL NOW
TURN TO THOSE IN OPPOSITION. I
UNDERSTAND THERE ARE TWO
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION- BERNIE
ROSCOE AND STEVE CARLSON MISTER
OSCO I SEE YOU IN THE GALLERY
PLEASE PROCEED. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS BERMAN
ROSTER WITH THE CALIFORNIA
CABLE AND TELECOMMUNICATIONS
ASSOCIATION. BUT WE ARE OPPOSED
TO SB TEN SIXTY NINE BECAUSE IT
WOULD MANDATE UNNECESSARY
REPORTS THAT WE ALREADY
GENERATE TODAY- THE KEY
SITUATIONAL UNDERSTANDING
AMERICAN SEE SITUATIONS AS AT
THE EMERGENCY SERVICES ACT.
PROVIDES THAT THE OFFICE OF
EMERGENCY SERVICES IT IS A LEAD
STATE AGENCY IN CALIFORNIA THAT
WILL COORDINATE ALL ACTIVITIES
ARE DONE STATE AND LOCAL. AND
THEY WILL COORDINATE WITH THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT. AS THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT PARTICIPATE.
THIS BILL LOOKS TO- ADD
SECTIONS IN THE PUBLIC
UTILITIES CODE SECTION THAT
ALREADY EXIST TODAY IN THE
EMERGENCY SERVICES ARE. TO KEY
PIECES THE LETTER RECENTLY WERE
ADOPTED BY THIS COMMITTEE AND
THE LEGISLATURE AND SIGNED BY
THE GOVERNOR THE FIRST BEING SB
EIGHT THREE THREE IN TWENTY
EIGHTEEN. SB EIGHT THREE THREE
LOOKED AT THE SITUATIONS OF
EMERGENCIES AND FALL SOME OF
THE SHORTCOMINGS OF HOW ISSUE
HOW EMERGENCY ALERTS WERE
ISSUED. THE IMPORTANT THING TO
UNDERSTAND ABOUT EMERGENCY
ALERTS AS WE ARE THE PLATFORM
FOR SENDING THOSE ALERTS
THROUGH. THE ALERTS ARE
GENERATED BY GOVERNMENT. THEY
AND ALL THE CONTENT IS FROM
GOVERNMENT CAN YOU THE
GOVERNMENT WILL DICTATE WHEN
AND YOU IF AND WHEN YOU WILL
SEND THOSE ALERTS. SO THE POINT
ABOUT STATUS ALERTS AGO AT. THE
EMERGENCY SERVICES ACT ALLOWS
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS TO CONTRACT
WITH THIRD PARTY VENDORS TO DO
REVERSE NINE ONE ONE CALLS.
THOSE ARE GOVERNMENT SANCTIONED
WROBEL. THERE ARE. THE MAIN AND
PHONE OR CLAIM BY LOCAL. PUT
INTO THE MACHINE AND THEN THOSE
ALERTS WILL GO OUT WHEN THE
GOVERNMENT ISSUES THOSE ALERTS.
THOSE WORDS MAY GO TO A CELL
PHONE AND MAY GO TO A COPPER
LANDLINE OR MAY GO TO AVOID
SERVICE. BUT THE ONLY ENTITY IN
THIS CHAIN THAT HAS ALL THAT
INFORMATION IS A THIRD PARTY
ROLL CALL. IN ADDITION-LAST
YEAR SENATE MCGUIRE HAD SB SIX
SEVENTY. THE PURPOSE OF THAT
BILL WAS TO PROVIDE SITUATIONAL
AWARENESS LOCAL GOVERNMENT WHEN
OUR NETWORKS THROUGHOUT THE
RESPONSIBILITY IS TO PROVIDE A
NETWORK ALEX REPORT. TO TELL-
YES THE ANALYSIS APPROPRIATE
CALLS OUT THEIR CODE SECTION IN
YOUR SECOND BULLARD OF EXISTING
LAW BUT WHAT IT FAILED TO. NO
WAS IN ADDITION TO TALKING THAT
INFORMATION ABOUT NETWORK
AVERAGES FOR SITUATION
AWARENESS DURING A DISASTER.
THERE'S ALSO THE RESPONSIBILITY
FOR CALIFORNIANS TO. NOTIFY ANY
APPLICABLE COUNTY OFFICE OF
EMERGENCY SERVICES THE SHERIFF
OF ANY COUNTY AND ANY PUBLIC
SAFETY ANSWERING POINTS ABOUT
THE ELDERS. THAT REQUIREMENT IS
ALREADY THERE AND STATUTES IN
LAW IT'S AS PART OF THE
EMERGENCY SERVICES ACT. SO IN
THE RESPONSE ABOUT WHAT HAPPENS
AFTER THE FACT EMERGENCY THE
EMERGENCY SERVICES ACT ALSO
REQUIRES CAL- YES WITHIN A
HUNDRED AND TWENTY DAYS. OF A
DISASTER TO PREPARE A REPORT TO
BE SURE WITH ALL PUBLIC SAFETY
ENTITIES ON HOW WELL THE
ENTITIES RESPONDED TO THE
DISASTERS AND WHAT ISSUES THAT
THEY DEAL WITH. SO AS FAR AS AS
WE TRANSITION TIME THE FINAL IS
UNNECESSARY. THE AMENDMENTS
THAT THE PROPOSED BY THE
COMMITTEE ANALYSIS WILL DO
NOTHING TO CHANGE OUR POSITION.
THIS THIS BILL IS REDUNDANT.
AND UNANSWERED. UNNECESSARY
THANK YOU. THANK YOU FOR US
GROW AND HAVE YOU THE THREE
MINUTES OF TIME AND THE-
PROBABLY WORKS UP IS MISTER
CARLSON HAS NOT ABLE TO GET TO
CALL IN SO WE WILL NOW LOOK FOR
ANYONE- ANY. OTHERS IN
OPPOSITION WHO WOULD LIKE TO.
BAKER IN THE GALLERY. YES
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS CHRISTMAS
KAYLEE ON BEHALF OF THE
COMPUTING TECHNOLOGY INDUSTRY
ASSOCIATION IN OPPOSITION THANK
YOU VERY GOOD THANK YOU MISTER
KELLY IS OR ANYONE ELSE IN THE
GALLERY SEE NO ONE WE MOVED TO
ROOM TWENTY FORTY SEEN NO ONE
IN ROOM TWENTY FORTY SO WE WILL
NOW MOVE TO- THOSE WAITING TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION VIA
TELECONFERENCE ORVIS MODERATOR
IF YOU WOULD PLEASE PROMPT THE
INDIVIDUALS WAITING TO TESTIFY
IN OPPOSITION TO SENATE BILL
TEN SIXTY NINE WE WILL BEGIN.
OKAY AND AS A REMINDER IF YOU
WOULDN'T WISH TO- QUEUE UP IT
IS ONE ZERO. OUR FIRST WILL
COME FROM THE LINE ONE EIGHTY
ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. MY NUMBER ONE EIGHTY ONE
YEAH YEAH. GOOD AFTERNOON THAT
THE DEAL ON THE BENCH NUMBER
HALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
COMMUNICATIONS ASSOCIATION. AND
OPPOSITION TO AT THE TEN SIXTY
NINE THANK YOU THANK YOU MISS
BENSON. NEXT OVER THE LINE ONE
NINETY EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. LADIES ALL
LOVE ON THE APPLE STRUCTURE
COMMUNICATIONS IN OPPOSITION TO
THE BILL. THANK YOU. NEXT NEXT
WILL GO TO THE LINE ONE SIXTY
TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. LINE ONE SIXTY TO YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. MOVING ON WILL GO
TO THE LINE TWO HUNDRED YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HI MY NAME IS WHAT MOMENT FROM
THE CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF
COMMERCE AND- WE RESPECTFULLY
CLOSE SB TEN SIXTY NOT THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. NEXT WE'LL GO
TO LINE ONE SIXTY FIVE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THANK YOU THIS IS PAM LIMóN
WITH CONSOLIDATED
COMMUNICATIONS IN OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU FOR THE TEST MONNING.
AND AS A REMINDER IF YOU WOULD
TO WISH TO OPPOSE PLEASE PRESS
ONE ZERO. OUR NEXT IS LINE ONE
EIGHTY NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THANK YOU
AND GOOD AFTERNOON MELANIE
FIGUEROA ON BEHALF OF VERIZON
IN OPPOSITION. THANK YOU. AND
RIGHT NOW WE DON'T HAVE ANYONE
ELSE IN Q. AS A REMINDER IT ONE
ZERO THANK YOU AND- APPRECIATE
YOUR CHECKING THAT ONE MORE
TIME JUST MAKE SURE WE'VE HEARD
FROM ALL OPPOSITION WITNESSES.
SINCE THERE ARE. SENATOR I'M
ADVISED THAT THE OTHER WITNESS
I HAD WAS STUCK IN THE
OPPOSITION Q. AND IS AVAILABLE
TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF THE
MEASURE I DON'T BELIEVE WE USED
OUR THREE MINUTES- BUT YOUR
TIMES SO. WE ARE. YES IN
OPPOSITION BUT WHEN WE SIGNED A
TIME THE OPPOSITION WE HAD. I'M
SORRY- THIS MONEY IS. SPOKE IN
SUPPORT SAINT PATRICK BEEN
ORDERS ON THE FOR THE LINE
THAT'S CORRECT WHO WILL GIVE MR
MEN ARE TO THIRTY SECONDS.
THANK YOU. MR MAYNARD IF YOU
ARE ON PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO AT
THIS TIME. I'M NOT SHOWING
MISTER MAYNARD QUEUING UP AT
THIS TIME. WELL. THE BEAUTY OF
TECHNOLOGY THANK YOU VERY MUCH-
MODERATOR I APPRECIATE THE GOOD
WORK TODAY- WE WANNA BRING THE
DISCUSSION BACK TO MEMBERS
MEMBERS HAVE ANY QUESTIONS OR-
COMMENTS. INSOFAR PLEASE- YES
SENATOR RUBIO. THANK YOU AND
AVERELL QUICKLY I WANT TO JUST
ABOUT THE AUTHOR ON THIS
MEASURE BUT A FIVE MADE JUST
FOR MY PERSONAL PERFECT CATION.
BOB CAN YOU CLARIFY THE MAIN
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN BOB ON THE
REQUIREMENTS. ON THIS BILL FROM
THE BILL FROM LAST YEAR.
SHERMAN THE KEY DIFFERENCE
THANK YOU. THROUGH THE CHAIR.
OF THE THIS BILL LAST YEAR WAS
SB FORTY SIX AFTER THAT BILL-
DIED IN APPROPRIATIONS I
DECIDED TO ADD IT MIGHT HAVE
BEEN A LITTLE BIT TOO HEAVY OF
WEIGHT. SO I DIVIDED THE BILL
IN TWO BILLS ONE IS THIS BILL
AND THE OTHERS ACTUALLY SB
SEVEN NINETY FOUR. WHICH WINS
COMBINED WITH SENATOR STEARNS
SP SEVEN FIFTY THREE WILL
INCREASE THE ROLES OF IN THOSE
IN OUR COMMUNITIES WHO ARE
ENROLLED INTO EMERGENCY WARNING
SYSTEMS WITH AN OPT OUT IF THE
CRUISE. THIS BILL IS THE OTHER
HALF OF SB FORTY SIX WHICH WAS
PASSED UP BY THIS- COMMITTEE
AND IT HAS TO DO WITH MAKING
SURE WE UNDERSTAND WHERE AND
HOW OLD. COMMUNICATIONS
INFRASTRUCTURE IS OPERATING AND
GIVING BOTH OUR EMERGENCY
MANAGERS AND OUR REGULAR HOURS
THE CPUS AB LADY. TEMPERATURE
WARNING. THANKS AND IN THEM
WHEN THOSE FAILURE OCCUR SO
THAT THEY DO NOT HAPPEN IN THE
FUTURE THAT IS THE BASIC
ESSENCE OF THIS BILL. SACRIFICE
THANK YOU SENATOR RUBIO OTHER
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS SEEING
NONE IS THERE A MOTION WOULD
YOU LIKE TO CLOSE SENATOR
JACKSON'S THANK YOU. SENATOR
AGAIN I WANT TO THANK THE
COMMITTEE FOR IT TO- THE
COMMITTEE STAFF FOR AN
EXCELLENT- ANALYSIS AND
ASSISTANCE IN CLARIFYING WITH
THIS BILL DOES AND DOESN'T DO.
I MIGHT SAY IT IS NOT REDUNDANT
IT'S ADDITIONAL TO CURRENT
REPORTING REQUIREMENTS AS THE
ANALYSIS POINTS OUT LOCAL AND
STATE EMERGENCY MANAGERS ALLEGE
THEY NEED THIS INFORMATION AND
IF YOU'LL TAKE A LOOK AT WHO
SUPPORT OF THIS. WE HAVE OUR
LAW ENFORCEMENT PEOPLE BECAUSE
IT IS ON THERE WATCH. THAT THIS
LEGISLATION OR AT THAT THAT
THIS ISSUE. IS TO BE ADDRESSED
AND BY AS YOU HEARD. MY A
COUNTY SAN WOULD HAVE HEARD
FROM THE- IT THE HEAD OF THIS
THE WITH THE COUNTY INTER THIS
IS SOMETHING THAT THEY-ARE
ANXIOUS TO HAVE SO THAT THEY
CAN IMPROVE UPON THE SYSTEM AS
NEEDED- SO THAT THEY CAN MAKE
SURE- THAT THEY CAN DO THEIR
JOB WE HAVE A
TELECOMMUNICATIONS NETWORK NOW
WHICH IS HOW WE SHOULD BE. A
WARNING PEOPLE- WHEN THAT FAILS
LITERALLY WE END UP WITH BOOTS
ON THE GROUND WITH WITH LAW
ENFORCEMENT COMING DOOR TO DOOR
KNOCKING ON PEOPLE'S DOORS. WE
USED TO HAVE CHURCH BELLS BACK
A HUNDRED TWO HUNDRED YEARS AGO
WE NOW HAVE TECHNOLOGY AND OUR
TELECOMMUNICATIONS- NETWORKS
HAVE GOT TO STEP UP HERE THIS
IS A MEASURE SUPPORTED BY THE
CALIFORNIA STATE SHERIFFS
ASSOCIATION. OF VARIETY OF
GROUPS THAT ARE CLEARLY
UNDERSTAND THE IMPORTANCE OF
MAKING SURE THAT THE TELECOMS
PARTICIPATE THAT THEY ARE
RESPONSIBLE THEY WILL WITH.
PREVENT KINDS OF TRAGEDY LIKE
WE IN PARADISE LIKE WE'VE SEEN
OUR THROUGH ALL THE DIFFERENT
FIRES AND WE ARE IN A FIRE
SEASON AGAIN- WE NEED TO DO
BETTER AND THIS BILL WILL HELP
US DO THAT WITH THAT I WOULD
RESPECTFULLY FOR YOU BOTH
KITCHEN HAVE TO DO. SB AND
SIXTY NINE. TO MOVE BY SENATOR
ROOM THE OTHER TO MOVE SENATOR
ROOM UP PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
AND TAT MAKES YOUR MICHAEL ARE
ON BEFORE VOTING. SB TEN SIXTY
NINE BY SENATOR JACKSON DO PASS
AS AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS.
SENATOR HILL I SENATOR HELD BY
BARLACH. SEC NO MORE LIKE NO.
BRADFORD CHIANG. DOLLY NO
TELLING THEM. DODD DODD I.
HERTZBERG MCGUIRE. PAN BY HAND
I. RUBIO I. RUBIO I. SKINNER
AYE SKINNER I STERN HI STERN I
WIENER HI WIENER I. SEVEN A IS
TO KNOWS. SO THE BILL HAS SEVEN
VOTES WILL HOLD A ROLL OVER FOR
THE OPTION MEMBERS SENATOR
JACKSON THANK YOU THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS. WHO. TO
THE THIRD ITEM ON OUR AGENDA.
FIFTY SB ELEVEN THIRTY BY
SENATOR GONZALEZ WELCOME GOOD
AFTERNOON. THANK YOU AND GOOD
AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR AND
COLLEAGUES- BEFORE I BEGIN I'D
LIKE TO ACCEPT THE COMMITTEE
SUGGESTED AMENDMENTS ON PAGE
NINE AND TEN OF THE ANALYSIS
WHICH WILL ADDRESS THE ISSUE
RELATED AND PERTAINING TO
RECEIVING TING FEDERAL GRANT
FUNDS AND CLARIFYING THAT
COMPLETELY UNSERVED AREAS WILL
CONTINUE TO BE PART. TIES AND
FUNDS THROUGH THE SPELL SO MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS I'M HERE TODAY
TO PRESENT SB ELEVEN THIRTY
WHICH IS A CRITICAL MEASURE TO
HELP CLOSE THE DIGITAL DIVIDE
BOTH DURING AND AFTER THE KOBE
NINETEEN PANDEMIC A LACK ACCESS
TO HIGH SPEED INTERNET WAS AN
ISSUE IN OUR COMMUNITIES EVEN
FOR THIS PANDEMIC TOOK HOLD THE
NEED FOR MODERN AND STRUCTURE
FUTURE PROOF AND SHIP
INFRASTRUCTURE HAS BEEN GREATLY
AND- WITH. THE MOVEMENT OF
HEALTH CARE WORK DISTANCE
LEARNING AND EDUCATION. AND
ONLINE PLATFORMS IN RESPONSE TO
COPE IN NINETEEN. ACROSS THE
STATE WE ARE SEEING EXAMPLES OF
HOW THE DIGITAL DIVIDE IS
PREVENTING CALIFORNIANS FROM
ENGAGING IN CRITICAL DIGITAL
ACTIVITIES. WHETHER IT BE
STUDENTS HAVING TO USE THIS
PARKING LOT- TO OBTAIN. ACCESS
TO WIFI CONNECTIONS TO DO THEIR
HOMEWORK OR OLDER CALIFORNIANS
WHO DO NOT HAVE FAST ENOUGH.
INTERNET TO RECEIVE TELEHEALTH
SERVICES OR TO CONNECT WITH
THEIR FAMILIES IN ALL PARTS OF
OUR STATE. OF THE COUNTRIES
HAVE FOR TECHNOLOGY AND THE
FIFTH LARGEST STATE THIS IS
SIMPLY UNACCEPTABLE AND WE CAN
DO MUST MUCH BETTER. A LACK
TERM INVESTMENT IN TWENTY FIRST
CENTURY READY BROADBAND
TECHNOLOGIES IS A KEY DRIVER OF
THE EXISTING DIGITAL DIVIDE SB
ELEVEN THIRTY WILL BEGIN TO
PROVIDE THE INVESTMENT NEEDED.
TO BUILD FIBER CONNECTIVITY TO
EVERY HOME SCHOOL AND BUSINESS
IN CALIFORNIA. SPECIFICALLY
THIS BILL REDEFINED THE
ELIGIBILITY REQUIREMENTS OF THE
CALIFORNIA ADVANCES. ADVANCED
SERVICES FUND TO ENABLE
INFRASTRUCTURE PROJECTS. THAT
REPLACE OUTDATED INTERNET
SPEEDS IN UNSERVED AREAS THIS
CHANGE IN CRITERIO UNABLE LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS AND INTERNET.
PROVIDERS OF ALSO. TO APPLY FOR
GRANTS AND AT THE SAME TIME
INVEST IN TWENTY FIRST CENTURY
AND INTERNET INFRASTRUCTURE.
THAT CAN MEET CALIFORNIANS
EVERY DAY NEEDS. THROUGH OPEN
THE PROGRAM'S. CURRENTLY THE
DOUBLE THE REQUIREMENTS FOR THE
CALIFORNIA SERVICES FUND ARE
TIED DIRECTLY TO LOW INTERNET
SPEEDS SIX DOWNLOAD ONE UPLOAD.
MAKING IN IT AT. LIKE SB IN
BUDGET WILL. TO NOTE THERE IS
OVER THREE MILLION SITTING IN
THE FUN THAT TO BE LEVERAGE
FROM VARIOUS OTHER GOVERNMENTAL
FUNDS AND SOURCES SB ELEVEN
THIRTY WILL ALLOW THE PC TO
PROVIDE GRANTS TO FINANCE OPEN
ACCESS HIGH SPEED BROADBAND
INFRASTRUCTURE PROJECTS THESE
CHANGES WOULD BRING CALIFORNIA
PAR WITH INTERNATIONAL
STANDARDS THIS MEASURE PROVIDE
A SOLUTION CHRONIC INTERNET
ISSUES AND RURAL URBAN RIVAL
AND SUBURBAN IS RATHER EIGHT.
NO HE WILL BE LEFT WE SIMPLY
EXPECT MORE AT ELEVEN THIRTY
DOES NOT PICK WINNERS AND
LOSERS SIMPLY ENABLES GRANTS
AWARDED BASED ON INTERNET
ACCESS AND SPEEDS NOT
GEOGRAPHY. 149% OF RURAL HOMES
WITH SCHOOL AGE CHILDREN HAVE
BROADBAND AND LOS ANGELES ONE
QUARTER OVER ALMOST THREE
MILLION STUDENTS TO DO NOT HAVE
ACCESS TO THE INTERNET AT HOME
CURRENTLY LIVE IN THAT IN THAT
IN BY. THEN OKAY IT REALLY ONE
THIRD. URBAN DISTRICT MINE. AND
REPORT THIS THAT MY COLLEAGUES
REFERS. ALL WORK TOGETHER MAKE
BROAD FOR ALL REALITY AND- I
ASK YOU TO JOIN ME IN A DIVERSE
COALITION OF FIFTY
ORGANIZATIONS IN ALL PORTIONS
OF OUR STATE. INCLUDING LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS EDUCATION LEADERS
ADVOCATES LABOR SMALL INTERNET
SERVICE PROVIDERS AND MANY MORE
IN SUPPORT OF SB ELEVEN THIRTY
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. I'M SPEAKING IN SUPPORT I
HAVE FOR NEXT TO FALL CON FROM
THE ELECTRONIC FRONTIER
FOUNDATION AS WELL AS JIM'S
DIRE. THE CEO COMMON SENSE
MEDIA. CHECK YOU SENATOR
GONZALEZ. WILL TO BEGIN WITH
ERNESTO FALCONE. PLEASE YOU MAY
PROCEED. IN YOUR TESTIMONY. YOU
THANK YOU THANK YOU THANK YOU
SHERYL- JAIL VICE CHAIR MORE
LIKE AN MEMBERS HE COMMITTEE
MY NAME IS ERNEST OF TALK OWN
I'M THE SENIOR LEGISLATIVE
COUNSEL FOR THE ELECTRONIC
FRONTIER FOUNDATION. ARE YEARS
OF RESEARCH IN A TWENTY FIRST
CENTURY ACT IS AND HOW TO MAKE
SURE NO ONE IS LEFT BEHIND- IT
DRY THIS IS SUPPORT SB ELEVEN
THIRTY THINGS LIKE REMOTE
EDUCATION VIDEO CONFERENCING-
CORROBORATE. OVER BOBBI SYSTEMS
THESE ALL NEED ADEQUATE
DOWNLOAD AND UPLOAD SPEED THAT
LEGACY NETWORKS ARE ARE NOT
ABLE TO PROVIDE NOR EVER WILL
PROVIDE. SB ELEVEN THIRTY BEGIN
THE PROCESS OF FIXING MANY BE A
LONG TERM FIX THESE PROBLEMS
COULD BE MAKING IT HIGHLIGHTS
WITH A TWENTY FIRST CENTURY
INFRASTRUCTURE. PROGRAM THAT
FOCUSES ON FIBER. FIBER WILL BE
KEY TO. MANY OF THE FUTURE.
BECAUSE THEY CAN IS THE
INGREDIENT FOUR INCH. OUR
FUTURE PROOF NETWORK- FIBER THE
UNIVERSE AND GREEN FOR- THAT
THE FUTURE OF THINGS LIKE
SPACEX THAT'LL CONNECTION FIVE
G. EXPIRATION WIFI. GIGABIT
BROADBAND NETWORKS ALL OF THESE
REQUIRE FIBER INFRASTRUCTURE.
ACCORDING IN SUPER SO FULL
UPPER LOCAL SELF RELIANCE A
NONPROFIT FOCUSED ON GOVERNMENT
INFRASTRUCTURE PROGRAM. FIFTY
MILLION DOLLARS CAN GET YOU
TWELVE MILES TWELVE MILES TO
PORTLAND ROAD FIFTEEN MILES OF
WATER PIPES OR DOZENS UPON
DOZENS OF MILES OF FIBER OPTICS.
SB ELEVEN THIRTY CHANGES SEEK-
TO REFLECT ADVANCEMENTS IN
BROADBAND THAT OCCURRED OVER
THE LAST FEW YEARS. IT IS A
MINIMUM OF TWENTY FIVE OR
TWENTY FIVE ON THAT ONE SURE
ABOUT THE CLOSE TO ONE POINT
FIVE MILLION CALIFORNIANS THAT
DO NOT HAVE. BROADBAND ACCESS
WILL BE PART OF ANY STATE
INFRASTRUCTURE EFFORT. AND THIS
IS CRITICAL GIVEN THAT SCALE AN
AGGREGATION OF THE DEMAND FOR
HIGH SPEED ACCESS WHICH IS ONLY
GROWN OVER TIME- CAN BE PART OF
ANY SORT OF LONG TERM FINANCING
AFTER BY THE STATE. THAT WILL
ATTRACT ADDITIONAL SOURCES OF
INVESTMENT CAPITAL TO MATCH ANY
STATE EFFORT HERE. IT'S
IMPORTANT TO KNOW BUT ANY
MARKET BETTY HI CABLE BROADBAND
SYSTEM HAS BEEN UPDATED IT WILL
BE ON TWENTY FIVE TO TWENTY
FIVE TODAY TO THIS WILL NOT
FINANCE NETWORKS. IN ANY MARKET
WHERE A CABLE COMPANY HAD
AGREED TO WHAT'S CALLED DOCKET
THREE POINT ONE WHICH IS
OCCURRED ACCORDING TO THE-
CABLE INDUSTRY DON'T PRESS
RELEASES MORE THAN A YEAR AGO.
AND LASTLY IT DOC THE
DEFINITION OF ON SERVICE- FOR
HIGH POVERTY AREAS. MAINLY
FOCUSING ON LOW INCOME
NEIGHBORHOODS AND PUBLIC
HOUSING PROJECTS. BUILD THOSE
ACCORDING TO FEDERAL DATA ALSO
LACK BROADBAND ACCESS AS MUCH
AS ANY OF RULE MARKET. AND
LASTLY BECAUSE THIS IS FOCUSED
ON FIBER INFRASTRUCTURE AND
WHICH IS IN A PROJECTOR WITH
EXTREME CAPACITY WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT AN ASSET. ON AN AVERAGE
ESTIMATE WILL BE USEFUL FOR
BROADBAND APPROVED FOR SEVENTY
YEARS AFTER CONSTRUCTION. THAT
MADE ANY TO SPEAK FINANCE
PROJECT. I HAVE TO BE OPEN
ACCESS IN ORDER TO SERVE IT
LISTS ALL THOSE WELL INTO THE
FUTURE- INCLUDING EVEN THE
OPPONENT THE LEGISLATION. IF IT
COMMENCED IN A GOOD FOREVER
HERE- WE'RE PROUD TO SUPPORT SB
ELEVEN THIRTY OF AS SPONSORS
AND WE REQUEST YOUR AYE VOTE
AND LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING
WITH THE COMMITTEE. THANK YOU
MISTER FLOOD PRONE- IT IS JIM
STAR ON THE CALL FOR HIS
TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT IF NOT
MODERATOR. PLEASE SEE IF HE HAS
CALLED IN ON THE
TELECONFERENCE. IS THAT
POSSIBLE. TO HAVE TRIMS TIRE.
OUR MOM. WHAT WE CAN DO WHILE
WE'RE WAITING FOR MR STIERS WE
WILL SEE IF THERE'S ANYONE IN
THE GALLERY FOR IT SPEAKING IN
SUPPORT HERE IN SUPPORT OF SB
ELEVEN THIRTY. SEEING NO ONE IN
THE GALLERY MOVING TO ROOM
TWENTY FORTY IS THERE ANYONE IN
TWENTY FORTY THERE'S NO ONE IN
TWENTY FORTY. WISHING TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT OF SB ELEVEN THIRTY.
SO IF WE. AT. MODERATOR DID YOU
FIND MISTER DYER. IF NOT THEN-
IF YOU WOULD OPEN THE LINES AND
CALL THOSE SUPPORTERS WHO ARE
HERE WISHING TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF SB ELEVEN THIRTY.
PLEASE. OKAY LINE. MY. OUR
THIRTY EIGHT MILLION AS THE
OPEN. NUMBER ONE TO THE LINE-
ONE THIRTY SEVEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD THANK YOU. GOOD
AFTERNOON- TREATY RYAN WITH THE
BROKEN REPRESENTS THE
CALIFORNIA AND ALSO ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA CENTER FOR
WORLD POLICY IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. TEXAS LINE TOO
OLD FOR PLEASE GO AHEAD. BACK
INDOLLARS NATIONAL ASSOCIATION
OF SOCIAL WORKERS CALIFORNIA
CHAPTER IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
NEXUS NINE ONE NINETY THREE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI I HAD SOME
COUNCIL MEMBER AND I'M ALSO
CHAIR OF THE NATIONAL.
COMMITTEE AND I'M SPEAKING AS
AN INDIVIDUAL TODAY I MEAN FOR
IF AMENDED I'D LIKE TO SEE THE
POVERTY RATE CHANGE FROM AT
LEAST 20% THRESHOLD DOWN TO
ONLY 10% HELLO HALF OF WIDER
NET. HEALTH CARE THE BILL.
TENSION THANK YOU. THANK YOU
FOR YOU TO. THANK YOU ARE
SUPPORTING ME PRESS ONE ZERO AT
THIS TIME- WE GO TO LINE TWO
THIRTEEN. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR AND MEMBERS MEGAN TWO
BIRDS ON BEHALF OF THE WRITERS
GUILD OF AMERICA WEST IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANKS TO
THE TO LINE OF ONE EIGHTY EIGHT
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU
CHAIR MEMBERS AND SENATOR
GONZALEZ THIS IS ANDREA BALL ON
THE HALF THE LONG BEACH UNIFIED
SCHOOL DISTRICT IN SUPPORT OF
SB ELEVEN THIRTY. THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TESTIMONY TODAY. NEXT WE
GO TO LINE A ONE FIFTY EIGHT P.
FINE. HELLO GOOD AFTERNOON THIS
IS PRESTON RAY FROM MONKEY
BRAINS HE AN INTERNET SERVICE
PROVIDER BASED IN SAN FRANCISCO
BAY AREA SPEAKING IN SUPPORT OF
SB ELEVEN THIRTY. THANK YOU.
NEXT WE GO TO LINE SEVENTEENTH
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO HELLO
THIS IS SEAN TO GET THEM OF
LAWSON WITH ACCESS HUMBLE IN
EUREKA AND WE SUPPORT SB ELEVEN
THIRTY STRONGLY THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. THANK YOU. MEXICO TO LINE
ONE NINETY TWO PLEASE CALL AT.
SURE MEMBERS WHEN THEY HAVE IT
OTHER THAN WHAT THE WIDENING
GROUP REPRESENTING NEXT GEN
CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. THANKS TO THE TO
LINE OF ONE THIRTY SIX PLEASE
GO AHEAD. CAN YOU COULD HURT ON
BEHALF OF THE COMMUNICATIONS
WORKERS OF AMERICA DISTRICT
NINE IN SUPPORT THANK YOU. NEXT
TO THE TREE LINE TWO ONE FOUR
TWO FOURTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HI THIS IS JIM SIRE FROM COMMON
SENSE MEDIA WE STRONGLY SUPPORT
THE LEGISLATION. THIS IS AN
EFFORT TO CLOSE THE DIGITAL
DIVIDE IN CALIFORNIA SOMETHING
THAT IS IN THE BEST INTEREST OF
EVERYTHING ALL CALIFORNIANS AND
THIS LEGISLATION WILL BE AN
INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT THAT
POURED IN THIS REGARD I'M A
PRIMARY WITNESS THE BEARING.
BUT THE BIGGEST THING I WANT TO
PAY IT I'M A PARENT AND AN
EDUCATOR LIVES IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. AND WE HAVE NOT HAD
MORE SIGNIFICANT LEGISLATION
THAT WILL IMPROVE THE EDUCATION
OF LOW INCOME KIDS AND- WELL
THE STATE. ONE SO I ONLY URGE
ALL OF THE PROJECT IN ITS- TO
SUPPORT THE CLUB REFLECTS. IT'S
TIME THAT WE ENDED DIGITAL
DIVIDE ONCE AND FOR ALL AND
THANK YOU SO MUCH OF SENATOR
GONZALEZ HEADING THE
LEGISLATION. AFTER MAKING THIS
AN ISSUE THAT LITERALLY TENS OF
MILLIONS OF CALIFORNIANS WILL
BENEFIT. SO IT IS GREAT TO HEAR
THAT THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
WILL WANT AND FOR ALL IF ALL
CHILDREN ALL FAMILY ALL SCHOOL.
THE OPPORTUNITY HAVE A HIGH
QUALITY EDUCATION IN THAT
MOMENT OF COLBERT NINETEEN
ONLINE LEARNING DIFFERENT
BURNING IS CRITICAL TO THE FACT
THAT YOU GUYS ARE HAVING
HEARING ABOUT THAT. CAN YOU
BELIEVE THIS LEGISLATION FORGET
TRAFFIC CENTER AGAIN DOLLARS
SHOULD BE ABSOLUTELY APPLAUDED
LEADERSHIP BUT EVERYONE ON THE
COMMITTEE SHOULD RECOGNIZE.
THAT WHEN ALL OF CALIFORNIA
KIDS LEARN WHEN ALL OF
CALIFORNIA. OUR WELL EDUCATED
THE BIG WINNERS EVERY. AND
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
SUPPORT OF THE TING CREDIBLE
IMPORTANT LEGISLATION THANK YOU
MR STEINER BUT WE FOUND YOU. TO
PROVIDE A MATE BY THE WAY AND
GOD BLESS YOU FOR DOING YOUR
JOB IN THE MIDST OF THE CALL
THE NINETEEN CRISIS. ATTIRE BUT
PLEASE NEXT TO. A SUPPORTER. ON
THE TELECONFERENCE LANDED IN
LINE AND- ONE THREE FOUR PLEASE
GO AHEAD. NINE ONE FORTY FOR
YOUR LINES OPEN. YES WE HEAR
YOU A LITTLE VENTURE BY WITH
THE GREEN LINING INSTITUTE IN
SUPPORT OF AT ELEVEN THIRTY
THANK YOU. THANKS TO THE LINE
ONE SEVENTY EIGHT PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER
CHAIR AND SENATORS HELLO AGAIN
REPRESENTING THE LOS ANGELES
COUNTY OFFICE OF EDUCATION IN
SUPPORT OF SB ELEVEN THIRTY
THANK YOU VERY MUCH WHICH GIVES.
BETTER TO LINE ONE NINETY ONE
HAD. YES THE GLOSSY HERNANDEZ
ON BEHALF OF TURN WE HAVE A
SUPPORT AMENDED PETITION AND
LOOKING FORWARD TO OUR
CONTINUED CONVERSATION. THANK
YOU MISTER HERNANDEZ. NEXT WE
GO TO LINE OF ONE SIXTY SEVEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
HEARING MEMBERS THEIR DOLPHIN
HAPPILY CALIFORNIA CITIES AND
SUPPORTED SB ELEVEN THIRTY
THANK YOU THANK YOU. ONCE AGAIN
IF YOU- SUPPORT PRESS ONE AND
THERE AT THIS TIME- NEXT TO THE
TO LINE TWO ONE. THE LINE IS
OPEN. THE NEXT SPEAKER WRITER.
AND OUT THE PERSON Q. AGAIN IF
YOU- WHICH IS SUPPORTED YOU MAY
PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME. SO
THERE'S NO ONE ELSE MODERATOR.
I THANK YOU VERY GOOD DOT NOW
THERE'S NO WELL THANK YOU. I'M
SORRY I DIDN'T HEAR YOU. THAT'S
CORRECT THERE'S NO ONE ELSE
THINKING OF VERY GOOD THANK YOU
VERY MUCH AND NOW WE WILL MOVE
TO THE OPPOSITION AND I
UNDERSTAND THERE IS ONE SPEAKER
IN OPPOSITION. AND ISSUES ON
THE CALL CAROLYN MCINTYRE. THE
FLOOR IS YOURS AND YOU HAVE
THREE MINUTES. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN I CAROLINE MCINTYRE ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA CABLE
AND TELECOMMUNICATIONS
ASSOCIATION IN OPPOSITION TO
THE BELL AND FIRST LET ME BE
CLEAR THAT WE ARE NOT OPPOSED
TO SB ELEVEN THIRTY BECAUSE OF
THE TWENTY FIVE THREE AS
AMENDED SPEED REQUIREMENTS AB
ONE OF THE SUPPORTING WITNESSES
POINTED OUT ALL OF OUR NETWORK.
EITHER MEET OR OPEN FAR EXCEED
THOSE. THE PROBLEM WITH THIS
BILL IS THAT IN TWENTY
SEVENTEEN THE CALIFORNIA
ADVANCED EVERYTHING'S FINE HAD
EIGHT REMAKE PURSUANT TO
LEGISLATION THREE HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS WERE MADE
AVAILABLE. FOR DEPLOYING
BROADBAND INTO UNSERVED AREAS I
WILL NOTE THAT THE PROGRAM HAS
BEEN AROUND SINCE TWO THOUSAND
AND EIGHT AND SO THIS IS THE
SECOND POT OF THREE HUNDRED
MILLION. THAT HAVE IN FACT BEEN
MADE AVAILABLE TO PEOPLE I
BROADBAND INTERNET WILL AREAS.
PROBLEM WITH THE BILL IS THAT
BY EXPANDING THE ELIGIBILITY
REQUIREMENT TO INCLUDE AREAS
THAT HAVE BE GREATER THAN SIX
ONE. WE'RE NEVER GOING TO GET
TO THE- BROUGHT IN THE AREAS
THAT HAVE NOT. IT IS A
PRIORITIZE THE POWER OF THE
STATE CALIFORNIA TO TRY AND GET
ALL INDIVIDUALS SOME FORM THAT
CAN ACTIVITY BEFORE EXPANDING
THE PROGRAM TO ALLOW FOR
FUNDING AND AFTER AREA. THE CBC
RECENTLY RECIEVED FIFTY TWO
APPLICATIONS FOR THEIR
CALIFORNIA SERVICES AND
PROGRAMS. IF ALL OF THOSE
PROGRAMS THAT WERE TO BE HANDED
OUT ALL. THE APPLICATIONS WERE
TO BE FUNDED. EIGHT FIVE
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS TO DO
SOUTH THAT PROGRAM IS A-
CURRENTLY ONLY HAS THREE
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS THIS
BILL OFFERS NO NEW SPENDING. SO
IT WOULD AGAIN REQUIRED THE
STATE TO. ATTEMPT PRIORITIZE
WHAT PROGRAMS NOW MEANING A
LARGER AREA WITHIN TWENTY FIVE
AND THREE THERE AGAIN I'M
LEAVING THE AREAS THAT HAVE NO
BROADBAND ACCESS AT ALL. SO A
NUMBER MANY PROVISION IN THE
BILL THAT WOULD ALSO ALLOW FOR
THE SPENDING AND MIDDLE MILE
AND PORTIONS OF THE NETWORK
UNDER CURRENT LAN. MALE MALE
CAN ONLY BE OFFENDED IF IN FACT
IT IS CAN PROVIDE SOME LAST
MILE RESIDENTIAL CAN ACTIVITY.
HE ENDED HERE A LOT OF THE CPC
TO PROVIDE LOANS TO INDIVIDUALS
THAT CAN NOT PAID UPGRADE THEIR
OWN NETWORK WHICH I WOULD
SUGGEST WOULD CALL INTO
QUESTION WHETHER OR NOT THEY
CAN AFFORD TO OPERATE A
NETWORK. SO THIS BILL HAD MANY
PROBLEMS WITH THAT AND IN ITS
EFFORT TO FUTURE PROOF. WOODS
NEED TO BE CONSIDERED ANYMORE
COMPREHENSIVE FRAMEWORK BUT THE
PRIMARY. PROBLEM HERE IS THE
FACT THAT KNOWS RULE
COMMUNITIES CONTINUE TO BE LEFT
BEHIND EVEN THOUGH THE BILL
THAT AND MANDATE TO SAY THAT
CONTINUE TO BE A PRIORITY THEY
HAVE ALWAYS BEEN A PRIORITY
SINCE TWO THOUSAND AND EIGHT
AND WE ARE NO CLOSER TO GETTING
THEM FOR CAN ACTIVITIES AND WE
WERE IN THIS PROGRAM BEGAN. LOS
RECENTLY OPPOSE ABOUT. HER
THANK YOU ENTIRE IS THERE.
ANYONE IN THE GALLERY WISHING
TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION TO
SENATE BILL ELEVEN THIRTY
SEEING NO ONE IN THEIR ANYONE
INTENT ROOM TEN FOUR TWENTY
FORTY. WHO WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION TO SB ELEVEN
THIRTY NO ONE THERE AS WELL. TO
HAVING HEARD FROM ALL
SUPPORTERS- IT WE WILL NOW MOVE
TO THE VISION OF HAVING HER FOR
THE OPPOSITION IN THE TWO ROOMS
AND THAT- WE HAVE. WILL NOW GO
TO THOSE- WISHING TO TESTIFY ON
THE TELECONFERENCE ORVIS
MODERATOR IF YOU WOULD PLEASE
PROP THE INDIVIDUALS WAITING TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION. TO BE
ELEVEN THIRTY WE WILL THEN IN.
HE WAS TESTIFYING OPPOSITION-
THAT'S THE ELEVEN THIRTY. AND
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. THAT
WAS TESTIFYING OPPOSITION BUT
THE BUT THE LEVIN THIRTY YOU
MAY PRESS ONE ZERO. WHEN. NINE
TO SEVENTEEN YEAR THE- LATE
SHOW LOVE ON THE OTHER FRONT
HERE COMMUNICATIONS
RESPECTFULLY IN OPPOSITION TO
THE BILL. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THE KENNEDY WHICH IS FINE
OPPOSITION YOU MAY HAVE ONE
ZERO AT THE TIME. TIME WE HAVE
NO THANK YOU. A VERY GOOD THANK
YOU COULD YOU JUST CHECK ONE
MORE TIME PLEASE IN THIS TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE'VE HEARD FROM
ALL OF THE OPPOSITION WITNESSES
ON SB ELEVEN THIRTY PLEASE
MODERATOR. SHARE IF YOU WISH TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION. YOU MAY
PRESS ONE AND ZERO AT THIS TIME.
AND AT THIS TIME THERE ARE NO
OTHER THANK YOU VERY GOOD THANK
YOU MODERATOR APPRECIATE THAT
VERY MUCH WHEN I BRING IT BACK
TO THE COMMITTEE. TIONS YES THE
SENATOR CHECK. THANK YOU MISTER-CHAIR OF THE GOALS OF THIS BILL
ARE TRULY COMMENDABLE OF
ALTHOUGH I'VE HAD CONCERNS
SIMILAR TO THOSE RAISED BY. THE
OPPOSITION. AXIS IS SUFFICIENT
ROBIN IS ESPECIALLY IMPORTANT
TODAY WHERE STUDENTS ARE.
EDUCATED THROUGH DISTANCE
LEARNING AND WORK IS BEING DONE
WITH VIDEO CONFERENCING LIKE
ZOOM AND I'M SURE WE'VE ALL
DONE ON A MILLION OF THOSE.
BECAUSE I'M VERY GLAD THAT
YOU'LL BE ACCEPTING THE
RECOMMENDED AMENDMENTS AND FOR
THE RATE THAT REASON I WILL BE
SUPPORTING TODAY- I DO HOPE
THAT YOU CONTINUE TO WORK WITH
THE OPPOSITION TO ADDRESS ANY
ISSUES THEY- MAY STILL HAVE
MOVING FORWARD. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SENATOR CHANGE
SENATOR DOLLY. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR AND MEMBERS I. FIRST WANT
TO SAY I HAVE THE- A LOT OF
RESPECT FOR THE AUTHOR SHE- DID
HER WORK SHE CALLED IN. AND
TALKED TO ME ABOUT HER BILL AND
I KNOW HAS TAKEN SOME
AMENDMENTS TO. TRY TO MAKE THE
BILL OF MORE- THE POSSIBLE FOR
RULE COMMITTEES BUT I WOULD
JUST LIKE TO. BACK UP AND CHECK
AB EIGHT SIXTEEN SIXTY FIVE WAS
A BILL THAT ACTUALLY THAT TO.
THIS MCINTYRE WAS SPEAKING
ABOUT WHICH WAS I WAS A JOINT
AUTHORED ON THAT BILL WITH THE
EDUARDO GARCIA AND SOME OTHERS
IN IN A COUPLE YEARS BACK IN
THE ASSEMBLY AND THAT WAS AT
THE TIME WHEN THE FUNDS WERE
ACTUALLY GONNA GO AWAY. AND
WITHOUT THAT BILL WE EXTENDED
THE PROGRAM AND ALLOW THOSE
FUNDS TO ACCRUE- SO. AT THE
TIME I WAS A REPRESENTING
ASSEMBLY DISTRICT NUMBER ONE
WHICH WAS TWENTY FIVE THOUSAND
SQUARE MILES AND THE REASON YOU
PROBABLY DIDN'T HAVE MANY
PEOPLE CALL ME OPPOSITION IS
BECAUSE THEY STILL DON'T HAVE
INTERNET AND THEY STILL DON'T
HAVE A PHONE SO THEY CAN'T
REALLY GET INVOLVED. GOVERNMENT
AND OUR GOAL WAS. YES POSSIBLE
OUR SCHOOLS AND OUR
CONSTITUENTS IN THOSE AREAS THE
ABILITY TO BE ABLE TO GET AT
LEAST SIX UP AND ONE DAY AFTER
ONE ONE SIX AND SO. WE HAVE A
HELL HECK OF A LOT OF-
APPLICANTS THEY'RE IN THE
PROCESS THE FUNDS HAVE BEEN
ACCRUING FOR SOME TIME AND
WORSE JUST STARTING TO SEE THE
PROCESS NOW FOR WE CAN GET.
THOSE COMMUNITIES THAT I HAVE
TRULY BEEN LEFT BEHIND AND I
AND ONE OF THE- TESTIMONIES
THAT WE HELD DURING THE PROCESS
OF AB SIXTY SIXTY FIVE WAS. I
WOULD LIKE TO GO TO ANYWHERE IN
IN A IN A POPULATED DISTRICT
AND I BET YOU I CAN TURN MYSELF
ON ON AND GET BETTER SERVICE
THAN I GET MY HOME RIGHT NOW
TODAY. AND SO. FOR THOSE
COMMUNITIES THAT ARE OUT THERE
I KNOW MISTER MCGUIRE
REPRESENTS IS. A TON OF THOSE
COMMUNITIES. MR DOT HAS SOME OF
THOSE AS WELL. IN HIS DISTRICT-
BUT THEY'RE GOING TO BE LEFT
BEHIND. THE THIS TWENTY FIVE
AND THREE HE- IS GOING TO
DELETE UP THE FUNDS THAT THEY
WILL THEY JUST. THEY'RE THEY'RE
IT'S- EXPENSIVE TO GET OUT OF
THOSE RULERS AND THAT'S WHY WE
EXTENDED THE FUN SO. I WOULD
LIKE TO WAIT A FEW YEARS AND
TRY TO GET. THOSE APPLICATIONS
FUNDED IN THOSE AREAS SO WE CAN
SEE THOSE COMMUNITIES. ACTUALLY
BE ABLE TO GET CONNECTED SO FOR
THOSE REASONS I WILL BE
OPPOSING THE BILL. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH SENATOR DOLLY OTHER
QUESTIONS YES SENATORS FOR.
THAT THANK YOU MISTER CHAR I
JUST WANTED TO. COMMEND THE
AUTHOR ON HER DILIGENCE ON THIS
MATTER I. YOU KNOW I. OFTEN
THOUGHT THIS WAS. SOLELY A
RURAL ISSUE. THIS CALL. CRISIS
THE BODIES IN OUR AREAS WERE
JUST MAG AND LAID TO BEAR YOU
KNOW WE HAD SOME SOME SOLID
RESPONSES FRANKLY FROM INDUSTRY
AND YEAH I WANT TO PARTICULARLY
MENTIONED SPECTRUM CHARTER WHEN
THEY STEPPED UP WITH LAUSD AND-
STARTED OFFERING THAT'S I THINK
IT'S SIXTY DAYS OF. OF FREE
INTERNET FREE INTERNET AND A
HOOK UP TO MAKE THAT HAPPEN BUT
I DON'T THINK WE CAN GET
THROUGH THIS. CONNECTIVITY
CRISIS WITH THOSE KINDS OF
GESTURES ALONE IN THE VISIONARY
NATURE THIS BILL. TRY DOING
ASSUME CALL ON TEN YOU KNOW TEN
AT SIX DOWN RIGHT TRIED TRY
DOING TRY FINDING SOME WAY TO
TAP INTO YOUR- YOUR CLASSROOM
AND HAVE AN INTERACTIVE VIDEO
CONFERENCE- I GET THE WE GOT TO
START SOMEWHERE AND I WANT TO
START SEEN AS MAKE PROGRESS IN
THOSE EARLY. YEARS BUT- I SEE
THIS AS IT AS MUCH AS A VISION
STATEMENT AS ANYTHING OF WHERE
WE REALLY NEED TO HEAD. AND
THAT HUNDRED TARGETING THAT
FUTURE PROOF. IS FRANKLY THE
ONLY DIRECTION WE CAN HEAD
WITHOUT STRAINING A BUNCH
ASSETS AROUND THE STATE THAT
FRANK THE PEOPLE CAN UTILIZE
IF. IF YOUNG PEOPLE ARE GONNA
LEARN IN THIS STRANGE NEW YEAR
SO AT THEAPPROPRIATE TIME I'D
LOVE TO BE ADDED ON AS A CO
AUTHOR. AND HELP IN THIS EFFORT.
SINCERELY APPRECIATE THE WORK
FROM CENTER OF FROM CENTER TO
THE NORTH AS WELL AS- A SIMILAR
GARCIA THIS EFFORT BUT- NOW'S
NOT THE TIME TO LET UP I
FRANKLY THINK WE NEED TO DOUBLE
DOWN. SO THANK YOU. THANK YOU
FOR THE COMMON SENATOR STERN
AND A SENATOR WIENER. THANK
YOU. MISTER CHAIR ACTING CHAIR.
OUR SUPPORT HI THIS BILL I WAS
PROUD TO SUPPORT IT WITHOUT THE
AMENDMENTS AS WELL- AND I WANT
TO REITERATE WHAT CENTER STERN-
I SAID THAT COOLEY I'M VERY
SUPPORTIVE OF MAKING SURE WE
CLOSE THE DIGITAL DIVIDE IN OUR
RURAL AREAS IT'S INCREDIBLY
IMPORTANT HAS MAJOR. EQUITY
ECONOMIC HEALTH PUBLIC SAFETY.
RAMIFICATIONS BUT I THINK
SOMETIMES THERE IS A-
PERCEPTION THAT WELL IF YOU'RE
IN A CITY OR TESTIFYING AND WE
KNOW THAT IN OUR CITIES WHETHER
IT'S- SAN FRANCISCO. OR LA SAN
FRANCISCO IS PERCEIVED AS A
VERY WEALTHY CITY WE HAVE
SIGNIFICANT POVERTY IN OUR
CITY. A LOT OF PEOPLE WHO
REALLY STRUGGLE. WITH DIGITAL
ACCESS SO IT IS. IT IS A HUGE
WORLD ISSUE BUT IS A HUGE URBAN
ISSUE AS WELL- AND BECAUSE OF
THE TO SEARCH YOUR NUMBER OF
PEOPLE LIVING. IN POVERTY IN
OUR CITIES THAT AFFECTS AN
ENORMOUS NUMBER OF PEOPLE- AND
HAS LIFELONG RAMIFICATIONS ARE
FOR PEOPLE WHO ARE TO BE ABLE
TO GET THAT ACCESS EARLY- AND
CONSISTENTLY BUT I DO SUPPORT
THIS BILL. SENATOR WIENER
SENATOR MORE UP SURE- MAYBE I'M
A LITTLE OLD FASHIONED BUT WHEN
I WAS YOUNGER I WAS INVOLVED
WITH THE SUMMER CAMP AND IT'S
A- ON THE WAY TO. BIG BEAR LAKE
ABOUT THREE DIFFERENT ROADS TO
GO UP TO. BIG BEAR LAKE IN THIS
WAS HIGHWAY THIRTY EIGHT OUT OF
MEN TONE. AND WE HAD NO
ELECTRICITY THERE WASN'T A LINE
THAT CAME ALL THE WAY FOR ALL
THOSE SUMMER CAMPS IN HOMES-
WOULD HAVE TO GENERATE THEIR
OWN ELECTRICITY. IT WAS SO WE
DID THAT FOR THE LONGEST TIME
BUT NEVER THOUGHT THAT OUR
NEIGHBORS SHOULD ALL. CHIP IN
AND SUBSIDIZE UP ONLINE. IT
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA EDISON TO
OUR FRONT GATE AND THEN HAVE US
ENJOY ELECTRICITY LIKE EVERYONE
ELSE. SO I'M KIND OF LOOKING AT
THIS BILL IN AND FROM THAT
PERSPECTIVE YOU KNOW YOU'VE GOT
AN INDUSTRY THAT. PROVIDES
DIGITAL TECHNOLOGY AND WORKS
FOR YEARS TO GET EVERYONE TO
PARTICIPATE AND NOW THERE ARE
SOME THAT. AREN'T ONLINE FOR
WHATEVER PARTICULAR REASON AND
NOW THERE'S SOME KIND OF
ENTITLEMENT. WHERE ALL OF A
SUDDEN ALL THOSE THAT ARE USING
THE SERVICE NOW HAVE TO
SUBSIDIZE THE ABILITY FOR
OTHERS. TO GET IT SO IT'S SORT
OF MORPHED INTO SOMETHING ELSE
SO I. I'M HAVING A LITTLE
DIFFICULTY WITH WITH THAT IDEA
THAT ALL OF A SUDDEN EVERYONE.
HAS TO SUPPORT FOR THOSE THAT
DIDN'T BECAUSE THEY WERE THERE
FIRST. AND IN AND OUT UNLESS
I'M MISSING SOMETHING I'M JUST
HAVING A LITTLE TROUBLE WITH
THAT CONCEPT SO JUST NOT A
QUESTION JUSTIFIED IT MAYBE THE
AUTHOR COULD. HELP ME IN HER
CLOSING REMARKS THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR AND- ACTION RIGHT
FOR. THANK YOU AND I TO WANT TO
COMMEND AUTHOR FOR HER EFFORTS
IN THIS AREA BUT- HI TO HAPPEN
CHALLENGES WITH THIS AS STATED.
A FEW YEARS AGO I DID A BILL
ARE IN REGARDS TO TRYING TO.
BRIDGE THE DIGITAL DIVIDE AND
OUR PUBLIC HOUSING- SECTOR USE
IN CA S. OFF AND ON I'M- I
THINK IT BEST THERE'S MIXED
REVIEWS ON THE SUCCESS OF THAT
PROGRAM AND THAT'S WERE MY
GREATEST CONCERN IS NOT AND-
TARGETING THOSE AREAS BUT
MAKING URE THOSE DOLLARS ARE
USED EFFECTIVELY- NOT ALL HOMES
NEED FIBER BUT THEY ALL DESERVE
MORE THAN DSL FOR SURE. AND IN
AREAS SUCH AS- ARE SENATOR FROM
ON THE FIRSTDISTRICT I MEAN
THEY NEED. CONNECTIVITY BASIC
CONNECTIVITY SERVICE AND- BUT
THE LACK OF DIGITAL SERVICES
NOT JUST A REAL ISSUE IT'S A
URBAN ISSUE AS WELL AS I STATED
AS- WE TRY TO ADDRESS AND MUCH
OF OUR- PUBLIC HOUSING HERE IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA AS WE
ALL KNOW- THE DIGITAL DIVIDE
IS. BASED ON TWO FACTORS ACCESS
AND AFFORDABILITY SO. I WOULD
HOLD. WE WOULD FOCUS OUR
CHALLENGES ON THERE I'M GOING
TO SUPPORT THE BILL TODAY BUT I
AM REALLY WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT- WE HAVE THE MOST
EFFECTIVE USE OF THESE FUNDS
GOING FORWARD AND MAKING SURE
THAT WE REALLY DRAW DOWN AND-
REACH TO COMMUNITIES THAT. NEED
TO SERVICE FIRST IS EXPANING
THAT WHICH IS ALREADY THERE SO-
INCREASING SPEED FOR AGAIN
COMMUNITIES AT OUR HOUSE
SERVICE SO I. REPORTED TODAY
THANK YOU. THANK YOU SENATOR
BRADFORD SENATOR RUBIO. THANK
YOU- WELL I ICE HERE ARE
DIFFERENT CONCERNS AND
DIFFERENT SITES OF BUT I ONE
THING I AM CONFIDENT IS AT THE
OFFICE IN A CONTAINER WORK TO
MAKE SURE THAT THIS BILL IS THE
VERY BEST THAT IT CAN BE BUT I
ALSO WANNA TRY TO PICK A TOWN-
ON NOT SENATOR WIENERS COMMENT
LIKE WE ALWAYS THINK THAT
BECAUSE YOU LIVE IN LA OR
THESE. EMAIL FREE SAN FRANCISCO
RICHER AREAS THAT SOMEHOW
EVERYONE'S COVERED BUT YOU KNOW
WHAT NINETEEN- AS AN EDUCATOR I
CAN TELL YOU RIGHT NOW THE CLUB
IN NINETEEN HAS HIGHLIGHTED
EMAIL SUCH A DEFICIENCY IN
TERMS OF ACCESS TO PORT.
UNDERSERVED COMMUNITIES AND I
COMMEND THE AUTHOR BUT I KNOW
THAT AGAIN I HAVE FULL
CONFIDENCE THAT SHOULD CONTINUE
TO WORK WITH EVERYONE TO ENSURE
THAT THIS IS THAT SHE MOVES
FORWARD IN THE BEST POSSIBLE
WAY BUT I THINK IT'S ABSOLUTELY
NECESSARY AND I ALSO ON A
SUPPORTIVE TODAY THANK YOU
THANK SENATOR RUBIO. THE CENTER
GONZALEZ WITH THE CLUB THEN
PERHAPS ENSURE THE RESPOND TO
THE COMMENTS AND QUESTIONS
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN THANK
YOU COLLEAGUES FOR ENTERTAINING
THIS AND THIS IS A VERY HEAVY
AND SPECIAL AND VERY
COMPLICATED- UP FROM THE TECHS
TURNS. BUT TO BUT I ABSOLUTE
I'M TAKING A INTO AND WILL
CONTINUE TO WORK WITH ALL OF
THE MEMBERS OF THAT WANT TO
WORK WITH US AND SURE WE GET
THIS AS WELL AS STAKEHOLDERS
WHAT I SAY. IS THIS BILL. THREE
IS ACTUALLY THE FCC THRESHOLD.
AND BENCHMARK SO WE'RE ACTUALLY
BEHIND THE FEDERAL BENCH MARK
AS IT STANDS NOW. AND IT'S JUST
NOT SUFFICIENT WE KNOW OF
COURSE AS MANY OF YOU ALLUDED
TO THAT. ALL OF US AROUND ZOOM
IS FOUR FIVE KIDS IN THE
HOUSEHOLD. TWENTY FIVE THREE IS
ACTUALLY THE BARE MINIMUM WE
SHOULD BE ACTUALLY. HAVING ONE
HUNDRED ONE HUNDRED. BUT THAT'S
YOU KNOW CERTAINLY FOR LATER
CONVERSATION AND THIS IS WHAT.
THE AMENDMENTS DO THEY PROVIDE
A GOAL FOR ONE HUNDRED ONE
HUNDRED. BUT REALLY SET THE
STANDARD AND BENCHMARK AT THE
FEDERAL LEVEL TWENTY FIVE
THREE. THE OPEN ACCESS PRATT
PROGRAM IS ALSO VERY ESSENTIAL
BECAUSETHIS ALLOWS FOR
COMPETITION FOR SMALLER- I. S.
P.'S. TO LOWER BARRIERS OF
ENTRY FOR LOWER ISPS.
ULTIMATELY TO LOWER THE COST
FOR SUBSCRIBERS WERE OUR
CONSTITUENTS. THAT DESERVE
LOWER COST ESPECIALLY IN THIS
DAY AND AGE. LASTLY THE PLOW OF
FOR BETTER AND- FOR ALL. AS
MANY AS OF MY COLLEAGUES
MENTIONED PLACES LIKE SOUTH LOS
ANGELES THAT BOTH SENATOR
BRAFORD AND I REPRESENT. ARE
ACTUALLYOFF THE GRID A LOT OF
PEOPLE THINK THAT THERE'S
ACCESS TO THE INTERNET. IS NO
IT. IN A- TO VERY HIGH COST.
YOU SEE THE- MAX THAT. YOU ALL
OF. A IN ITS PLACE HAVE NO
ACCESS ALL AND THERE ARE MANY
OF IN COUNTY THAT DO NOT THEM
AND BEING AS AS WE ARE. AT ONE
TRY MEANS TENS OF PEOPLE FOR.
BUT UP WE WILL COME TO SIR THE
AND ROLL COMMUNITY AS THIS
INSURED PRIORITY FOR THOSE. AND
WE WILL COME WORK TWENTY
THERE'S DID LITERACY PROGRAM
WHICH WAS THE AIR OF SICK SIX
FIVE PRIOR TO THIS SB THIRTY
BUT I JUST ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE
RESPECTFUL ANYTHING A ALL OF
YOU FOR AND IN THIS. I LOOK FOR
TO A WITH YOU THANK YOU SENATOR
GOING TO DO. SB ELEVEN SO OF
THE BY SENATORS THANK YOU HAS
PLEASE THE ROLL. SB ELEVEN
THIRTY BY SO AT LEANA CONSULT.
TO PASS ASTHMA TO HER. HILL HI
HILL HI MORE LAW NO MORE NOT
KNOWN. DEFERRED OUR BRADFORD I.
CHIANG KAI CAN I. DOLLY NO
TELLING THEM. DOT HI DON I.
HERTZBERG REQUIRED BY WIRE I.
PAN HI HAND I. RUBY HI RUBIO HI.
SKINNER SKINNER I STERN HI EARN
I. WIENER BY WIENER HI. TEN A
IS TO KNOWS. IT WILL HOLD THE
ROLE OPEN FOR UP TO MEMBERS
THANK YOU VERY IN CANADA
GONZALEZ WHEN I MOVED TO ITEM
NUMBER FOUR ITS PEAK TWELVE
FIFTEEN BY SENATOR SHERMAN.
PLEASE PROCEED. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS FIRST OFF
I JUST WANT TO THANK THE
COMMITTEE STAFF ONE EIGHT I
WILL BE ACCEPTING THE
RECOMMENDED AMENDMENTS AND
SINCERELY APPRECIATE THEIR HARD
WORK ON THIS BILL AS WELL AS
THE WILDFIRE WORKING GROUP- LED
BY CENTERS RUBIO AND REQUIRED
DO APPRECIATE ALL THE
ENGAGEMENT HERE. THIS IS ONE
PIECE OF WHAT WE HOPE TO BE A
MORE COMPREHENSIVE SOLUTION TO
OUR P. S. P. S. CHALLENGE IN A
STATE WHICH FRANKLY IS NOT
GOING AWAY WILDFIRE SEASON IS
ALREADY UPON US THE OVERALL
COST THE ECONOMY THUS FAR IS
ESTIMATED BY ONE STANFORD
ANALYSIS- TO BE ABOUT TEN
BILLION DOLLARS. AND SO WE'RE
LOOKING AT THE PIKE AT ANOTHER
SEE OF COMPARABLE SCOPE AT THE
IDEA OF THIS BILL IS TO
CONTINUE TO MAKE THE PROGRESS
THAT BEGAN WITH SB THIRTEEN
THIRTY NINE WITH. WHICH THE CPC
HAS BEEN IMPLEMENTING
DILIGENTLY AND TRYING TO GET
SOME PROGRESS MADE BEFORE THIS
WILDFIRE SEASON UNFORTUNATELY
WE DON'T THINK. THAT OR ARE
GENERATE AND CENTER PRO. WILL
HAVE. IN OUT. TO OUR- TO REALLY
GET THIS THEM THROUGH THIS NEXT
ROUND OF CRISES SAFELY- WE'RE
TRYING TO. BRING ALL
STAKEHOLDERS TOGETHER AND I DO
APPRECIATE THE INPUT NOT JUST
OF THE THIRD PARTIES- BUT OF
THE UTILITIES WHO I THINK OF A
CRITICAL ROLE TO PLAY IN- IN
OUR MAKER AGREED. AND SELF
GENERATION SYSTEM LABOR- OUR
REPAIR ADVOCATES ARE LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS OF THOSE WHO
OPERATOR INDEPENDENT LIVING
FACILITIES AND OTHER KEY STAKE
HOLDERS SO- I THINK THE MAN.
THIS BILL DOWN REALLY TO ITS
ESSENCE WHICH IS SOME WAY TO.
YOU WE'RE BE DEPLOYED PUTTING
OUT THAT OF SOLAR DE SYSTEMS
AROUND THE STATE FOR A IN THERE
TO SITTING THERE BEHIND METERED
NOT YOU TO ANY ELSE IN THE THIS
GRAY WE THINK THAT ASSET COULD
BE WASTED LIKEWISE WITH MICHAEL
WE WANT TO MAKE SURE IT AS
BROAD BENEFIT IF THE REPAIRS
ARE ACTUALLY GONNA BE FUNDING
THIS ACTUALLY THINK THERE IS A
ROLE FOR NON REPAIR FUNDING AS
WELL- BUT OF WITHIN THE SCOPE
OF THIS BILL OF WITH JUST A PRE
MOVING THE COMP. FORD AND
HOPEFUL GETTING SOME URGENT
ACTION DONE NOT ENOUGH HAS BEEN
CONSTRUCTED SO FAR NOT ENOUGH
OF THESE SYSTEMS HAVE BEEN PUT
OUT THERE BEFORE THIS SEASON SO
HOPEFULLY THIS WILL JUMP START
THE CONVERSATION WITHOUT OVER
MICROMANAGING THE PUBLIC
UTILITIES COMMISSIONS PROCESS
STILL WITH THAT RESPECTFULLY
ASK YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. FIRM WE HAVE. LISTED
SUPPORT WARNING. SPEAK SO WE
WILL NOW LOOK FOR ANY SUPPORT
IN THE GALLERY. SCENE NO ONE
HERE WISHING TO SPEAK GOING TO
TWENTY FORTY THERE'S NO ONE IN
ROOM TWENTY FORTY WISHING TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT. SO WE WILL
NOW GO TO THOSE- ON THE LINE
MODERATOR IF YOU WOULD PLEASE
PROP THE INDIVIDUALS WAITING TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF SB TWELVE
FIFTEEN. WE WILL BEGIN. OKAY
ONCE AGAIN IF YOU DO WELL BY
AGREED LIKE CAPITAL ZERO OUR
FIRST LINE IS A LINE TO NINE
PLEASE GO AHEAD YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HI THERE THIS IS AND
HIGHER FROM THE BILL VALLEY
GROUP AND WE'RE TO SEE THE BILL
THANK YOU SOME. GOOD THANK YOU.
NEXT WE'LL GO TO THE LINE TO.
YEAR LAW IS OPEN THESE GO AHEAD.
YOU CAN TELL. ON BEHALF OF
HEALTH HELLO SO AND STORAGE
FIFTY. WE HAVE A IF I'M COULD.
OF ARTICULATED ARE TO AND I
BETTER BUT OUR. FACEBOOK FOR
THE AUTHORED LEADER AND WE URGE
THE BILL MOVED FORWARD THANK
YOU. THE COMMISSION. YOU. THE
NEXT WE'LL GO TO THE LINE ONE
SEVENTY NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO THIS IS
ALLEY B. TRIO AT THE
MICROBREWERY SOURCES COALITION
AND REIMAGINE POWER IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF THE BILL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. NEXT IS
LINE TWO OH NINE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON BRIAN CHONG CITY OF
MOORPARK REGISTERING SUPPORT
FOR SB TWELVE FIFTEEN THANK YOU
THANK YOU. NEXT IN LINE TWO TWO
NINE TWO HUNDRED TWENTY NINE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON HER JOHNSON WITH THE
CLIMATE CENTER IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF THE BILL THANK YOU.
VERY GOOD THANK YOU. NEXT WE'LL
GO TO LINE TWO TWO SEVEN TWO
HUNDRED AND TWENTY SEVEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. WHICH CAN JONES
WITH A THREE FIFTY BAY AREA
ACTION IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL.
THANK YOU MISTER JONES. NEXT TO
VOTE ONLINE TWO TWO ZERO TWO
HUNDRED AND TWENTY YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. MEDICARE NUMBERS THEN
WHAT ABOUT- WHAT THE WIDENING
GROUP ON BEHALF OF BLOOM ENERGY
AND QUIRK THANK YOU. NEXT TOTAL
WINE TO THIRTY ONE TWO HUNDRED
THIRTY ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
KEY CARE MEMBERS JOHN DORY AND
PERHAPS ON RUN WE SUPPORT THE
MEASURE AND HOPE WE CAN SUPPORT
THE AMENDMENT THE REPORT BY
CALIFORNIA SOLAR IN STORES SO
CAJUN. AND SILICON VALLEY
LEADERSHIP OR ANYTHING. ONCE
AGAIN IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO
QUEUE UP IT IS ONE ZERO. THE
LAST ONE WE HAVE BEEN Q. RIGHT
NOW IS LINE TO EIGHTEEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELP FROM THE CALIFORNIA LANES
FOR COMMUNITY ENERGY IN SUPPORT
OF THE BILL. VERY GOOD THANK
YOU VERY MUCH MODERATOR IF YOU
COULD JUST CHECK ONE MORE TIME
TO SEE IF THERE'S ANYONE. ON
THE LINE WISHING TO VOICE THEIR
SUPPORT FOR S. P. OF. TWELVE
FIFTEEN. PLEASE OKAY. AS A
REMINDER IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO
QUEUE UP IT DOESN'T ONE ZERO.
ONCE AGAIN IT IS ONE ZERO. WE
DO HAVE ONE THAT IS CUED UP ONE
MOMENT IT COMES FROM THE LINE
TWO THREE THREE TWO HUNDRED
THIRTY THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
COULD POSSIBLY YOU MUTED
YOURSELF ONE TWO THREE THREE.
AND I'M NOT HEARING ANYTHING
COME FROM THEIR LINE. ALL RIGHT
THANK YOU WE WILL NOT BRING IT
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE TO LIST
TO HEAR FROM THE OPPOSITION WE
HAVE ONE REGISTERED SPEAKER IN
OPPOSITION- VALERIE TO RUSSIA
FROM PACIFIC GAS AND ELECTRIC-
YOU HAVE THREE MINUTES. IF YOU
ARE ON THE LINE. GOOD AFTERNOON
MISTER CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE ACT GALLERY TO
RELIVE LOT HAS WITH THE CIVIC
ACT IN A LECTURE COMPANY. YOU
NEED TO HAVE AN UP CLOSE TO THE
ACTION ON THE BILL AND CURRENT-
BUT I FIRST WANT TO BEGIN-
EXPRESSING GRATITUDE TO THE
AUTHOR THE AUTHOR STAFF AND THE
NEED FOR THE TIME. THAT THEY
SPENT TO ENGAGE WITH OUR
CONCERNS THAT WE RANGE- ON THE
BILL CURRENT MANY QUESTIONS IN
PARTICULAR. ABOUT THE PROCESS
THAT ONE BUILDING NOW IN THE
CURRENT MICHAEL GREAT PRECEDING
AT CPAC- SO THERE IS A CLAIM-
FOUR MICROGRAMS- ALONG WITH
OTHER- ACTION. AS WE BUILD- ARE
RESILIENCY AND AS ONE ASPECT OF
BOND FIRE MITIGATION THAT WE'RE
ALL WORKING SO HARD TO ADDRESS
AS WE PREPARE COURSE FOR THIS
SEASON AND BEYOND- I WANT TO
THANK THE AUTHOR FOR TAKING
ECONOMY AMENDMENT. NOW OF OUR
CONCERNS AND THE OPPOSE LETTER
SO WE WILL CONTINUE TO WORK
WITH THE AUTHOR AND COMMITTEE
AS THE BILL MOVES FORWARD. ON
HEY- THIS AND PARTICULARLY ON
THE SPECIFICS OF BILL PROVISION
DEFINITIONS AND THE DATABASE
REQUIREMENTS. WE WANT TO ENSURE
ALIGNMENT WITH THE TEAM HE-
REQUIREMENTS AND THAT WE'RE
MANAGING COSTS. AND PRESERVING
SOME FLEXIBILITY- FOR THE PC AS
WEAK AS CONDITIONS INVOLVED.
WE'RE NOT ABLE TO OFFICIALLY
REMOVE OPPOSITION TODAY BUT THE
BILL OF TAKING A VERY GOOD
THAT- IN THE RIGHT DIRECTION-
THANKS AGAIN AUTHOR- IN THE
COMMUNITY. THIS CONCLUDES MY
TESTIMONY THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR THE TESTIMONY TODAY AND NOW
WE WILL GO TO ANYONE IN
OPPOSITION IN THE GALLERY.
WHICH MEMBERS BERNIE OROZCO
WITH CALIFORNIA CABLE AND
TELECOMMUNICATIONS ASSOCIATION
WE ARE SUPPORTER OF MICRO GRIDS
BUT WE ARE OPPOSE UNLESS
AMENDED- WE HEAR THAT THE
DATABASE CREATION IS TOO
COSTLY. FOR THE SHORT NUMBER
OF. APPLICATIONS MAY RECEIVE. I
THANK YOU FOR THE TESTIMONY
TODAY IN THE GALLERY ANYONE
ELSE IN THE GALLERY SHE NO ONE
WILL MOVE TO TWENTY FORTY IS OR
ANYONE THERE WISHING TO TESTIFY
IN OPPOSITION. NO ONE THERE
WILL NOW GO TO THE- PHONE LINES
SO MISTER A MODERATOR IF YOU
WOULD PLEASE OPEN THE LINES FOR
THOSE IN THE TELECOM COMPOUND
PRINT SERVICE WHO ARE WISHING
TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION TO SB.
TWELVE FIFTEEN. OKAY A IN ONCE
AGAIN IF YOU'D LIKE TO QUEUE UP
IT IS ONE ZERO. OUR FIRST WILL
COME FROM THE LINE TWO THIRTY
FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HELLO CAPTAIN BOARD
WITH SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
EDISON- WOULD LIKE TO THANK THE
AUTHOR FOR EVERYTHING THAT IS
DONE SO FAR ON THE MEASURE AND
THE AMENITIES TAKEN-
UNFORTUNATELY WE'RE STILL IN
OPPOSITION AT THE MOMENT AND I
WILL KEEP WORKING WITH THE
AUTHOR THANK YOU. FOR YOUR
THANK YOU FOR THE MOON. AND
NEXT WE'LL GO TO THE LINE TWO
THIRTY TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HE LATE SHOW
OF ON BEHALF OF FRONTIER
COMMUNICATIONS WE HAVE AN
OPPOSING LEFT AMENDED POSITION
SIMILAR TO THAT OF A CALIFORNIA
CABLE TELECOMMUNICATIONS
ASSOCIATION THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. AND NEXT WE'RE GOING TO
THE LINE OF. ONE THIRTY SIX ONE
HUNDRED THIRTY SIX GO AHEAD
YOUR MIND IS OPEN. DâN EVERY
TERRACE ON BEHALF OF THE
UTILITY REFORM NETWORK TURN BY
TURN SUBMITTED A LETTER OF
CONCERN AND WE LOOK FORWARD TO
FURTHER CONVERSATION LOOKING
FORWARD. VERY GOOD THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT NEXT WE'RE GONNA GO
TO THE LINE. TWO TWO EIGHT TWO
HUNDRED AND TWENTY EIGHT YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
WELL TO THE CALIFORNIA
MUNICIPAL UTILITY ASSOCIATION
WERE ACTUALLY A TWEENER
DOMINANT VISUAL POSITION. WE
HAVE BEEN DISCUSSING CONCERNS
WITH AUTHORS OFFICE WANT TO
THANK HIM AND ITS STAFF. AFTER
MOVING THE BILL FORWARD TODAY
WITH THE AMENDMENTS WE LOOK
FORWARD TO FURTHER
CONVERSATIONS AND OUR MEMBERS
ARE THE SUPPORTERS OF THE
COMMUNITY TO MAINTAIN ELECTRIC
RELIABILITY DURING WEATHER
EVENTS THROUGH COMPREHENSIVE.
WELFARE MEDICATION PLANS AND
THE SWEET A BETTER THAN
MEDICARE'S AND WE I THINK YOUR
TIME LOOK FOR DEBT. FURTHER
CONVERSATION THANK YOU MISTER
WELCH. AND WE DO HAVE ONE MORE-
IN OPPOSITION IN Q. IF YOU DO
WANT TO QUEUE UP IT'S ONE ZERO.
THE COMES FROM THE LINE ONE
FIFTY FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR
ISRAEL CALLING WITH TEN DIEGO
GAS AND ELECTRIC I WILL- ECHO
THE COMMENTS MADE BY THE
MUNICIPAL UTILITIES AND THE TWO
AND BY THROWING UTILITIES. WE
SUBMITTED- IN OPPOSITION LETTER
BUT WILL BE REVIEWING A
RIVETING OPPOSITION IN LIGHT OF
BE. RECOMMENDED COMMITTEE
AMENDMENT THAT WERE ADOPTED
TODAY THANK YOU THANK YOU. IF
pTHE HELLO WOULD YOU LIKE TO ADD
A DIFFERENT REALLY EMBARRASSED
I'M I'M CALLING ON BEHALF OF
THE INDEPENDENT ENERGY
PRODUCERS ASSOCIATION I WAS
SUPPOSED TO BE- LISTED AS A
LEAD RIGHT NOW AND WHEN THEY
GET BANNED A NUMBER HOW. CAN I
STILL GET THE COMMENT. THE YES
THE IN SUPPORT IS THAT WHAT
YOU'RE SAYING. IT'S AN
OPPOSITION YEAH SO LET'S LOOK
AGAIN- OR DO YOU TECHNOLOGY
WITH THE JEANS ABOUT TWENTY
SAID YEAH NO I JUST WANTED.
ALRIGHT PERFECT WILLING TO GET
GOING- AND I JUST WANT TO GIVE
A BIG THANK YOU FIRST OFF AGAIN
TO THE AUTHORED OFFICE FOR
WORKING CLOSELY WITH BACK ON
AND THEN MAKE DETECTION TO
EIGHTEEN AND EXPANDING OUR GET
CREDIT- WORK NO WORKING TO
REACH A FULL SOLUTION- WE'RE
LOOKING AT. ADDING TERMINATING
WHETHER OR NOT THE DATE- I
JANUARY IS GOING TO BE. JANUARY
TWENTY TWENTY. TWENTY TWENTY
TWENTY ONE I'M GONNA BE
SUFFICIENT ENOUGH- FOR TO BE PC
AND HIGHER HI SO. DEVELOP A
METHODOLOGY TO ACCOUNT FOR THE
RESORT ADEQUATE DISTRIBUTED
STORAGE. WE'RE GONNA REMAIN
OPPOSED INTEL WE CAN WE CAN
FILE BIBLE CONCLUSION ON THAT
ASPECT BUT AGAIN YOU. THE
AUTHOR. FOR THE WORK THAT THEY
DID ON THE AMENDMENT THAT ARE
VERY GOOD THANK YOU VERY MUCH
I'M GLAD WE WERE ABLE TO GET
YOU IN. HERE. MODERATOR COULD
YOU. THANK YOU COULD YOU CHECK
THE LINE ONCE AGAIN JUST TO SEE
IF ANYONE THAT. THAT ONCE UP TO
ASK TWELVE. OKAY AND AS A
REMINDER IT IS ONE ZERO IF
YOU'D LIKE TO QUEUE UP TO
OPPOSE. AND WE HAVE NO ONE IN
Q. AT THIS VERY GOOD THANK YOU
MODERATE OR APPRECIATE THE
GREAT SERVICE TODAY THANK YOU.
FOR THE SUPPORT AND OPPOSITION
WITNESSES AND SO AND TESTIMONY
WILL NOT BRING THE DISCUSSION
BACK TO MEMBERS ANY QUESTIONS
COMMENTS OR CONCERNS YES
SENATOR RUBIO. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR- WELL FIRST I WANT I
REALLY COMMEND THE AUTHOR FOUR.
INCHES HIS COLLABORATIVE SPIRIT
HE HAS BEEN WORKING ON THIS
ISSUE PART OF BAD DâN REALLY
HAS BEEN VERY GENEROUS WITH HIS
TIME AND- ALSO WOULD BE
AMENDMENTS TAKE AND HE REALLY
DID ENGAGE ALL OF US FOR
SEVERAL. MONTHS I CAN SEE THAT
HE'S ALMOST THERE WITH THE
OPPOSITION AND THAT'S JUST A
TESTAMENT OF HIS. COLLABORATION
AND THE WORK HE'S DONE TO
ENSURE THAT EVERYONE'S VOICES
ARE HEARD AND- SO I'D LIKE TO
ADD MY NAME IS A CO AUTHOR WHEN
APPROPRIATE AND I WOULD BE
SUPPORTING ITSELF. THE BILL
THANK YOU SENATOR RUBIO OTHER
QUESTIONS COMMENTS CONCERNS.
SEEING NONE SENATORS FOR WOULD
YOU LIKE TO CLOSE. YES THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR- AND THANK YOU
TO MY COLLEAGUE FROM THE SOUTH
SIDE OF. ARTIST MY DISTRICT A
WE'RE ALL WE'RE ALL KINDA IN
THIS TOGETHER WHETHER YOU'RE
FROM AN URBAN PART OF LA OR A
RURAL PART OF THE NORTH COAST-
IN ORANGE COUNTY OR- IN THE
HILLS OF ALAMEDA COUNTY- GUY TO
KEEP THE LIGHTS ON AND WE'VE
GOT TO FIND A SMARTER WAY TO
PLAN FOR THESE PROCESSES SO
HOPEFULLY THIS BILL MOVES THAT.
BALLDOWN THE LINE AND WE CAN
GET THROUGHTHIS NEXT FIRE
SEASON A LITTLE SAFER WITHOUT
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR RIVAL
THANK YOU SENATORS FOR AND WE
HAVE A MOTION ON ITS B. TWELVE
FIFTEEN. WE HAVE A MOTION FROM
SENATOR RUBIO- THANK YOU AND
THE SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. SB TWELVE FIFTEEN BY
SENATOR STERN DO PASS AS
AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS. HILL
BY HILL AYE MORE LOOK. BRADFORD
CHIANG. DOLLY DOT. HERTZBERG
MCGUIRE HI MCGUIRE HI PAN HI
CAN I RUBIO AYE RUBIO AYE
SKINNER AYE SKINNER I. STERN BY
STERN I. WIENER RIGHT WIENER I.
MORE LIKE. BRADFORD CAN DOLLY.
DOT DOT NINE. ACE. WILL HOLD
THE ROLL OPENS THE BILL HAS A
POUCH WILL HOLD THE ROLE
CONTRAPTION FOR THE OPTION
MEMBERS WHEN I MOVED TO ITEM
NUMBER FIVE SB THIRTEEN TWELVE
BY SENATOR MCGUIRE. GOOD
AFTERNOON OR GOOD EVENING I
SHOULD SAY. PLEASE PROCEED WHEN
YOU'RE RADY SENATOR MCGUIRE
THANK YOU SO MUCH MISTER CHAIR
VERY GRATEFUL- AND GOOD EVENING
COMMITTEE IN KNOW THAT IT'S
BEEN A LONG DAY FOR EACH AND
EVERYONE OF YOU FIRST OF ALL I
DO WANT TO SAY THANK YOU TO YOU
I CHAIR HUESO. FOR HIS WORK ON
THIS AND EXPERTISE TO HAVE HER
ATTENTION TO THIS LEGISLATION
THEY SPEND AN AWFUL A LOT OF
TIME ON THIS WE'RE VERY
GRATEFUL AND OF COURSE WILL BE
ACCEPTING THE COMMITTEE
COMMITTEES AND THEN IT'S NOTED
IN THE ANALYSIS TODAY MISTER
CHAIR HOUSE ONE TAKE AMONG THE
STATE THANK YOU TO SENATOR
STERN FIRST PARTNERSHIP ON THIS
BILL IS A JOINT AUTHORED. SB
THIRTEEN TWELVE TAKES CRUCIAL
STEPS CRUCIAL STEPS TO ENSURE
THE UTILITY POWER SHUT OFF
EVENTS HAVE SMALLER FOOTPRINTS
THIS YEAR SHORTER DURATIONS AND
PROPER OVERSIGHT IN DOING SO IT
REQUIRES INVESTOR OWNED
UTILITIES PART TO PRIORITIZE
PUBLIC HEALTH AND SAFETY AS
WELL AS A POLL THE BELIEF THAT
CALIFORNIANS SHOULD HAVE THE
RIGHT TO RELIABLE ELECTRICAL
SERVICE IN THIS DAY AND AGE BY
THE WAY WERE IN TWENTY TWENTY.
LAST YEAR BROUGHT AN
UNPRECEDENTED LEVEL OF POWER
SHUT OFF OF IN SPITE UTILITIES
ESPECIALLY WITHIN THE P.
JEANNIE SERVICE TERRITORY
CUTTING CALIFORNIANS TO WONDER
IF THE NEW NORMAL BE A LACK OF
POWER FOR DAYS OR EVEN WEEKS ON
END. GAINING IN SEPTEMBER OVER
TWO MILLION RESIDENTS LOST
POWER ACROSS FORTY COUNTIES
SHUT OFF A VINCE OCCURRED WITH
SUCH FREQUENCY THAT THEY BLED
INTO EACH OTHER AS THE INTERNET
I WOULD. MEAN RESIDENTS WITHOUT
POWER OF FORTY DAYS IN A THIRTY
DAY. ITALY P. JEANNIE IN
PARTICULAR MUST DO BETTER.
CURRENTLY THE CALIFORNIA PUBLIC
UTILITIES COMMISSION REQUIRES-
UTILITIES TO FILL OUT REPORTS
AFTER POWER SHUT OFF OF THESE.
THESE REPORTS HOWEVER OFTEN
LACKEY INFORMATION IMPROPER
REVIEW. ADDED THE DOZENS OF
REPORTS FILED LAST FALL THE
PUBLIC UTILITIES COMMISSION
DIDN'T DO THREE HEARINGS NOT TO.
THEY ONLY DID ONE OFFICIAL
REVIEW ANY HEARING. THIS IS
SIMPLY NOT GOOD ENOUGH FOR
CALIFORNIANS OUR STATE LACKS A
FORMAL PROCESS FOR FUTURE
REVIEWS OF SHUT OFF EVENTS IN
CLEARLY THE LEVEL REVIEW
WITHOUT ONE HAS BEEN
INSUFFICIENT AT BEST. SB
THIRTEEN TWELVE PROVIDES THE
NECESSARY FRAMEWORK TO DECREASE
THE FREQUENCY OF POWER SHUT OFF
OF INS AND ALTERNATELY
ULTIMATELY ELIMINATE THEIR USE
BY REQUIRING INVESTOR OWNED
UTILITIES YOU TAKE BOTH SHORT
AND LONG TERM STEPS TO HARDEN
THEIR INFRASTRUCTURE. AS WELL
AS MODERNIZE IS WELL. SO HERE'S
WHAT IT DOES NUMBER ONE IT
AUTHORIZES THE CALIFORNIA
OFFICE OF EMERGENCY SERVICES
CALIFORNIA AND THE PUBLIC
UTILITIES COMMISSIONTO CREATE
CONSISTENT PROCEDURES FOR POWER
SHUT OFF OVENS IN THE BEST
INTERESTS OF CALIFORNIANS.
HERE'S WHAT THIS MEANS ALL
THREE OF THESE AGENCIES ARE
WORKING TOGETHER ON WHAT THE
NEED NOW IT MAKES SOME COME
TOGETHER IN COLLABORATION WHEN
IT COMES TO THE TYPE OF
NOTIFICATION IS A NEED. WHEN
THE- HOW ALL DO UTILITY
REPAIRALE. WHAT FOOT PRINT IS
GOING TO BE INSURING THAT ALL
THE AGENCIES THAT ARE INTACT.
BY THESE UTILITIES. INDIGO
RIGHT IS REQUIRED COLLABORATE.
NUMBER EVERY WHAT I TO IDENTIFY
POWER LINES ARE MORE LIKELY TO
CAUSE POWER SHUT OFF A VINCE OR
WILDFIRES IT PROHIBITS THE IOUS
FROM CHARGING CALIFORNIA. OR
ELECTRICITY NOT BY THE- IN A-
WHEN THE POWER IS CUT REQUIRE
SIDE USED TO INCLUDE DETAIL
ABOUT THE LAW. AT CAR THE
POWERSHOT OFF OF THE THIS IS.
IN THERE AFTER EVENT REPORTS
HOW MANY MILES A LINE WERE
IMPACTED OR HOW MANY CIRCUITS
ARE IMPACTED IT WOULD REQUIRE
THAT INFORMATION DOWN THE
DETAIL AND THAT IS NOT
CURRENTLY REQUIRED. THIS WILL
ALLOW STATE AGENCY TO TRULY CAN
IT WHERE THE PROBLEMS ARE
WITHIN THE GREAT INDEED SELECT
AT ABOUT A FIX IT PLAN. IT ALSO
REQUIRES. THE WHOLE HERE. TO
WHETHER A POWER CHARLOTTE IN IS
IN COURT. WITH STANDARD. IN
AUTHORIZED TO LEVY FINES IF
NEEDED AFTER EVERY POWER SHUT
OFF. AFTER EVERYONE OF THEM. IF
CALIFORNIANS ARE GOING TO BE IN
PAIN. AND SURE ENOUGH THE
REGULATOR SHOULD BE IN PAIN
LISTENING TO WHAT THE
CHALLENGES ARE OF CALIFORNIANS
ON A DAILY BASIS. IT ALSO
REQUIRES A USER HARDEN THEIR
INFRASTRUCTURE THAT CAUSES THE
POWERSHOT OF A VENN. REPORT
BACK TO THE PUBLIC UTILITIES
COMMISSION ON AGGRESSIVE ONE
AFTER THE SHUT OFF OF. RIGHT
NOW UTILITIES ARE BEHIND BEHIND
YEARS IN THERE HER NAME AND
EDUCATION MANAGEMENT ESPECIALLY
WITHIN THE- PACIFIC GAS AND
ELECTRIC- TERM. LASTLY THIS
BILL WILL NOT BY THE EXISTING
UNDERGROUND INSTAGRAM AT THE
UTILITY COMMISSION. THE PULL
OUT IS IN HIGH RISK FOR HIS.
IT'S RIGHT. WHILE YOUR FEET THE
BILL IS SUPPORTED BY THE STATE
FIRST THE FIRE CHIEF SALINAS IT
CAN'T THE AND SO SHE
ASSOCIATION AND THE REASON
BEING EACH ONE OF THESE
AGENCIES EACH ONE OF THESE
AGENCIES HAVE TO RESPOND
ESPECIALLY IN THE P. JEANNIE TO
SPUR SURGERY AS THE EMERGENCY
MANAGEMENT SYSTEM FOR PACIFIC
GAS ELECTRIC WE'VE BEEN WORKING
CLOSELY WITH THE ARE YOU USING
FOR CO WORKERS ON THE- BUDGET
AND THEY'LL- WE WANT TO SAY
THANK. BUSINESS HERE ENGAGE.
WITH MADE IN IMMENSE LAST WEEK
TO ADDRESSSEVERAL CONCERNS
MOST NOTABLY MAKING SURE THAT
SB THIRTEEN TWELVE TWELVE.
ALIGNS RATE OF RETURN WHAT AB
TEN FIFTY FOUR IT WAS REALLY
CRITICAL AND IT MADE SENSE. AND
WE'RE GOING TO CONTINUE TO WITH
ALL STAKEHOLDERS TO ADDRESS
CONCERNS ARE BILL. OUR GOAL
IT'S NEVER TO THROW THE
EXISTING C. P. C. PROCESS OUT.
BUT THE BILL IN AREAS WHERE WE
START GAP LAST FALL IN IN THE
CURRENT PROCEEDINGS. SB
THIRTEEN TWELVE PROVIDES A
FRAMEWORK TO ENSURE THAT SHUT
OFF OF VINCE BECOME THE TOOL OF
LAST RESORT. AND NOT THE
DEFAULT STRATEGY. BUYERS NOW
HERE WE CAN ANTICIPATE A NUMBER
OF POWER SHUT OFF THE VINCE AND
IT'S GONNA BE SOON. THE FATE AS
FAR. SO MY- TIONS WITHIN THE
PEACH. THIRTY GOING FORWARD
HOWEVER WE CANNOT LEAVE
COMPANIES IN THE- I HAVE TO DO
IT TO PROVIDE TESTIMONY TONY
GOZER A FIRE CHIEF FOR THE
GREAT CITY CENTER. IN I
APOLOGIZE BUT SURE IF HONI
WHO'S THE BUTTE COUNTY SHERIFF
WAS GNNA BE WITH THIS HE'S
CURRENTLY IN A MEETING BUT
WE'RE RUNNING A LITTLE BIT
BEHIND HEY. GOING TO JUMP ON
THE LINE. TO CHEER BUT I SURE
PHONY MAYBE ALSO WITH US FROM
THE BUTTE COUNTY SHERIFF'S
OFFICE. MISTER CHAIR I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR IT I DON'T
KNOW I'M GRATEFUL FOR THE TIME
ANSWER I WENT TO LONG. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH SENATOR REQUIRE
AND WE WANT NO **** YOUR
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OF FIRST
WILL BE A- CHIEF. AGING
INSURANCE. GOD PARK. THIS SANTA
ROSA. THE LAST THREE YEARS
THIRTY SANTA ROSA AND SONOMA
COUNTY HAS EXPERIENCED
DEVASTATING FIRES IN OUR REGION.
IN TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN WE
EXPERIENCE THE TUBS FIRE WHICH
CONSUME FIVE THOUSAND SIX
HUNDRED THIRTY SIX STRUCTURES
AND THIRTY SIX THOUSAND ACRES.
STRADDLING WE HAD TWENTY TWO
FATALITIES ASSOCIATED WITH. AS
A RESULT THERE'S BEEN AN
INCREASE IN THE USE OF POWER
SHUT OFF. LAST FALL SHOWN THAT
THE POWERSHOT A PROCESS NEEDS
IMPROVING. BOTH RESIDENTS AND
FIRST RESPONDERS. IN TWO
THOUSAND NINETEEN CINEMACON
EXPRESS FIVE POWER SHUT OFF.
IMPACTING THOUSANDS OF
RESIDENTS EACH OCCURRENCE
DURING THE THIRD POWER SHUT OFF
ON OCTOBER TWENTY THIRD WE
EXPERIENCE YOU CAN KID FIRE
WHICH CONSUME THREE HUNDRED
SEVENTY FOUR STRUCTURES AND
OVER SEVENTY SEVEN THOUSAND
ACRES. SENATE BILL THIRTEEN
TWELVE WILL PROVOKE WON'T
IMPROVE PUBLIC SAFETY BY HAVING
SMALLER AND LESS FREQUENT
POWERSHOT. WE KNOW PUT OUR
COMMUNITIES AT RISK. SENATE
BILL THIRTEEN TWELVE CREATES
THE FRAMEWORK TO SHORE AND
INCREASED PUBLIC SAFETY POWERS
PROBLEM. AND TO ALTERNATELY
REDUCE THEIR USE. IT ALSO
REQUIRES INVESTOR OWNED
UTILITIES TO TAKE BOTH SHORT
AND LONG TERM STEPS TO HARDWARE
INFRASTRUCTURE. I RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST YOUR AYE VOTE ON SENATE
BILL THIRTEEN TWELVE. THANK YOU
FOR YOUR TIME. THANK YOU CHIEF
APPRECIATE THE TESTIMONY TODAY
OF WE WILL NOW GO TO SINCE I
UNDERSTAND THAT- SHERIFF- HANYA
IS NOT- AVAILABLE SO WE WILL
NOW GO TO THOSE SUPPORTING. SB
THIRTEEN TWELVE IN THE GALLERY
WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK. THANK YOU
MY NAME IS KATHERINE
BRANDENBURG REPRESENTING
CINEMACON POWER WERE IN SUPPORT
OF THE BILL. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH BURKE WERE ANYONE ELSE IN
THE GALLERY WISHING TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT SB THIRTEEN TWELVE WE
KNOW TO OUR ROOM TWENTY FORTY
NO ONE THERE WHICH INDUSTRY
SUPPORT NOW WE WILL GO TO THE
TELEPHONE CONFERENCE. IN AND
THE MORE. WOULD Q. A THOSE INTO
WISHING TO SPEAK SUPPORT OF SB.
TWELVE PLEASE BEGIN. OKAY AND
AS A REMINDER IT IS ONE ZERO IF
YOU WISH TO BEING Q. FOR
SUPPORT. OUR FIRST WILL COME
FROM THE LINE. TWO TO THREE TWO
HUNDRED AND TWENTY THREE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. HI IT'S JOHN
KENNEDY WITH THE WORLD COUNTY
REPRESENTED THE CALIFORNIA WE
REPRESENT THIRTY SEVEN WORLD
COUNTIES THAT RUNS THE
BLASTERS. YES SOMETIMES WE HAVE
A SUPPORT COMMENDED DEDUCTION
ON THE BILL- WE STRONGLY
SUPPORT THE AUTHOR'S INTENT TO
INCREASE OVERSIGHT AND REDUCE
UTILITY RELIANCE ON POWER THANK
YOU. A PUBLIC FIFTY POWER SHUT
OFF OF THEM. WE APPRECIATE THE
REASON TO SPEND MONEY- WE THINK
THEY VERY MUCH GOING RIGHT
DIRECTION. WE DO. HAVE SOME
SUBJECT AMENDMENTS TO PRESERVE
EXISTING PUBLIC MORE. PROCES
AND IN THAT YOU HAVE YES ABOUT
FROM. IS SHARED WITH HELLO YEAH
LOCAL EMERGENCY MANAGERS
CONTEMPORANEOUSLY- WE LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH THE
AUTHORS TO ADDRESS. ISSUES AS
THE BILL MOVES TOWARD AND THANK
THEM VERY MUCH FOR ADDRESSING
THIS ISSUE. THANK YOU THANK YOU.
NEXT WE'RE GONNA GO TO THE LINE
TWO THIRTY EIGHT YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HEY JAMIE
MIGHT HAPPEN MARIN CLEAN ENERGY
IN THE COURT THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. SIR I THINK I SAID THAT
WITH MY ME BUT NOT ITS LINE ONE
FIFTY TO YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
THANK YOU GOOD EVENING MISTER
TERRACES MARK THANKS TO MAKE-
ON NAPA VALLEY CLEAN ENERGY AND.
THANK YOU NEXT WILL GO TO
ONLINE TWO THIRTY IN YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. SHE
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS CHASE AND I COULD ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY TOWARDS ASSOCIATION
ALSO LOOK TO PORT. THANK YOU
FOR THE TESTIMONY. NEXT WE'RE
GONNA GO TO THE LINE ONE SIXTY
SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD EVENING HERE IN
MEMBERS THERE DAHLE CAN HAPPEN
AGAIN CALIFORNIA CITIES IN
SUPPORT OF SB THIRTEEN TWELVE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. NEXT
WE'RE GONNA GO TO THE LINE TO
THIRTY SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MISTER CHAIR
AND MEMBERS GREG COOK
REPRESENTING THE NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA POWER YOU SEE THIS
IS IMPORTANT BILL AND WE ARE
DRIVE BOTH THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MISTER COOK. AND ONCE AGAIN IF
YOU WISH TO QUEUE UP FOR A-
SUPPORT PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO.
THE FINAL THAT WE HAVE BEEN Q.
RIGHT NOW IS GOING TO FORTY
TWO. YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. THANK YOU GOOD
AFTERNOON MR TERM MEMBERS WHO
SHALL MUCH ARE HERE ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA STATE
SHERIFFS ASSOCIATION. AND
CALIFORNIA UNABLE TO MAKE IT
OUT LET THE SUPERVISOR AND- I'M
WE KNOW THAT YOU COMPANIES HAVE
BEEN TREATED ME YOU. PS YES
WHAT THAT GOAL OF UC. THE FIVE
AND FREQUENCY OF WILD I LIKE TO
COOK WITH GREAT THING
CALIFORNIA JOB THAN THE NORMAL
EVERY. YEAR HE THEN WE BELIEVE
AS SHARE AND THAT IT IS VERY
AND THAT COSTA ARE IN PLACE TO
ENSURE THAT. DEMAND COULD NOT
TO RELIABLE SERVICE YOUR
SERVICE. AND THAT THE OF. ON
FIRST OR SECOND DETAIL PEOPLE
IMPROVE THE PUBLIC SAFETY AND
COMMUNITY CONNECTED HER VITAL
SERVICES. FORTY THREE THERE THE
CALIFORNIA STATION ASSOCIATION.
SUPPORT AT THE- TRIAL THANK YOU.
SO MUCH THANK THANK YOU FOR THE
TESTIMONY. WE DO NOT HAVE
ANYONE ELSE IN Q. MODERATE IF
YOU WOULD PLEASE CHECK THE LINE
ONCE AGAIN JUST TO BE SURE THE
REFERRED FOR ALL THE SUPPORT.
WITNESSES FOR SB THIRTEEN
TWELVE. OKAY LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO
IF YOU'D LIKE TO QUEUE UP IN
SUPPORT ONCE AGAIN ONE ZERO.
AND WE HAVE KNOWING QUEUING UP
AT THE TIME THANK YOU MODERATE
APPRECIATE THE HELP AND THE
GOOD SERVICE TODAY WE'VE HEARD
FROM SUPPORTERS NOW WE WILL
TURN TO THE OPPOSITE END WE
HAVE TO. REGISTERED TO THE
SPEAKERS OF OPPOSITION THEY
HAVE A TOTAL OF THREE MINUTES-
BETWEEN THE TWO OF THEM AND- I
SEE. WHICH UP IN THE GALLERY TO
A MISTER WHICH YOU MAY BEGIN.
YES MISTER CHAIRMAN MEMBERS GOT
WAY SHOULD BE OFF THE
CALIFORNIA COALITION OF UTILITY
EMPLOYEES IN THE STATE
ASSOCIATION OF ELECTRICAL
WORKERS. LIKE TO THANK THE
AUTHOR FOR WORKING WITH US. A
AND- MOST RECENT AMENDMENTS ARE
OPPOSITION IS RIDLEY DOWN TO
ONE. BUT VERY SIGNIFICANT ISSUE
WHICH HAS TO DO WITH CREATING
AN ENTIRELY NEW METRIC OF
REPORTING. AND OF HARDENING OF
TREES MISSION IN DISTRIBUTION
SYSTEMS. MEMBERS JUST LAST YEAR
WE PASSED AB TEN FIFTY FOUR WE
CREATED A WILDFIRE SAFETY
DIVISION CHARTER. WITH PERCY
THE PROGRESS IN THE PLANNING
OF. PARDON THIS IS THE OF THE-
INFRASTRUCTURE. WE CREATED A
WHAT ARE SIX. MORE TO BY FIRST
PROGRESS OF THAT TYPE OF WAR.
WE ARE CONCERNED BECAUSE WE
THINK THAT THE ARBITRARY TIME
FRAMES PLACED ON THIS VERY
COMPLEX AND DANGEROUS WORK IS
GOING TO ENDANGER THE LIVES OF
OUR MEMBERS BY FORCING
CONTRACTORS UNDER PRESSURE FROM
THE UTILITIES TO WORK TO GET
THINGS DONE FASTER THAN IN AND
WITH WITH OUT. FALLING ALL THE
SAFETY MEASURES THE SERVER
SECTOR. MEMBERS OF THE NEW IS
TO OCCUPATION SAFETY AND HEALTH
UTILITY LINE WORK IS ONE OF THE
DEADLIEST PROFESSIONS WITH
FIFTY SIX POINT THREE DEATHS.
FOR ONE HUNDRED THOUSAND
WORKERS. TO PUT THAT IN
PERSPECTIVE KOBE NINETEEN IN
THE U. S. AS OF TODAY HAS A
DEATH RATE OF NINE POINT THREE
PER ONE HUNDRED THOUSAND
POPULATION. WE DON'T NEED
ANOTHER METRIC FOR HARDENING
AND WE DON'T NEED TO CREATE
ARBITRARY TIME FRAMES THAT
FORCE DANGEROUS WORK TO BE
DONE. WITHOUT AN EYE TOWARD
SAFETY SO- OUR POSITION IS
OPPOSE UNLESS OMITTED THANK
YOU. THANK YOU MISTER WHAT
SHOULD WE HAVE ON THE LINE ADAM
SMITH- MISTER SMITH ARE YOU
AVAIL. ONE MOMENT MISTER SMITH
AND ALL OPEN YOUR LINE.
SPEAKING IN OPPOSITION TO SB
THIRTEEN TWELVE.
CAN YOU HEAR
ME YES WE CAN. WELL GREAT THANK
YOU THAT ADAM SMITH SEVEN
CALIFORNIA EDISON RESPECTFULLY
OPPOSE THAT THE THIRTEEN
TWELVE- PRIVILEGES LIKE TO
START BY THANKING SENATOR
MCGUIRE IS OFTEN. FOR THEIR
OPENNESS AND WILLINGNESS TO
TALK THROUGH THE ISSUES WITH
REYES THANK YOU KNOW RECENT
AMENDMENTS IMPROVE THE BILL
FROM OUR PERSPECTIVE MAYBE WITH
THE EXCEPTION OF THE UNDER
CUTTING LANGUAGE BUT I JUST
LIKE TO WHICH THEY HAVE NOT AT
OUR CORE CONCERNS WITH ALL THE
PERCENTAGE. AND DATE IN THE
BILL WITH TWELVE WITH STILL
REFOCUS THREE PRIORITIZE
UTILITY WORK AWAY FROM STV'S
CURRENT APPROACH. WOULD. THE
MOST. YOU MEAN LIKE. BACK TO
POSSIBLE YOU ADVANCED MALL
TOOLS PRIORITIZE OUR WORK THE
IS WHAT WE PROPOSED AWHILE ME
TO GET PLAN THIS IS WHAT WE ARE
IMPLEMENTING THAT. SB THIRTEEN
TWELVE COULD HAVE UTILITY MORE
NARROWLY FOCUSED OUR WORK
PARTITION WITH THEM DUE TO THE
POTENTIAL FOR PUBLIC SAFETY
POWER SHUT OUT ON CERTAIN
CIRCUIT. IF IT'S FOR HIGH END
UP IN THE BILL METHODOLOGY WE
BELIEVE THAT IT IS IN THE
PUBLIC. INTEREST AND THE
INTEREST FOR PUBLIC SAFETY THAT
ARE EXISTING WAR PRIORITIZATION
NOT BE AUGMENT. WAY ANYTHING
CONTINUE CRY. OUR WORK WHETHER
THAT TWO DAYS OUT TWO WEEKS OUT
FOR TWO YEARS OUT IN A WAY THAT
REDUCES THE RICH. OUR SYSTEM
SPARKED THE FIRE AND REDUCES
THE RISK TO HUMAN LIFE AND
PROPERTY. AS I MENTIONED AT THE
TOP WE- THE SENATOR AND STAFF
AS THEY WORK WITH THAT YOU
UNDERSTANDING THE BALANCE HERE
YOU KNOW WE LOOK FORWARD TO
CONTINUING THOSE CONVERSATIONS
BUT E HAVE TO OPPOSE THE BILL.
IT'S WRITTEN TODAY. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR THE TESTIMONY
WILL NEVER ANYONE ELSE IN THE
GALLERY WISHING TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION TO SB THIRTEEN
TWELVE. SEE NO ONE WILL GO TO
OUR OVERFLOW ROOM TWENTY FORTY
THERE'S NO ONE THERE WISHING TO
SPEAK WE WILL NOW GO TO THE
WITNESS- THOSE WILLING TO
WANTED TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION. TO SB THIRTEEN
TWELVE ON THE TELECONFERENCE
ORVIS MODERATOR IF YOU WOULD
PLEASE PROP THE INDIVIDUALS
WAITING TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION OF SB THIRTEEN
TWELVE WE WILL THEN BEGIN. OKAY
THE REASON GERMAN IF HE WOULD
DO WISH TO KILL UP TO OPPOSE
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO. OUR
FIRST LINE IS LINE ONE FORTY
SEVEN. PLEASE GO AHEAD YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON
MEMBERS NIKOLAY NOT AMENDED
WITHIN DIEGO GAS AND ELECTRIC
ALSO WANT TO SAY WE THINK THE
AUTHOR AND BAFFLE WORKING WITH
THE INVESTOR OWNED UTILITIES AT
THE MOMENT WE MET RESPECTFULLY
OPPOSE THANK YOU. THANK YOU
THANK YOU. NEXT WE'RE GONNA GO
TO THE LINE ONE THIRTY SIX YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THE INTERPRETER CARRIES ON
BEHALF OF THE UTILITY REFORM
NETWORK TURN BY TURN SUBMITTED
A LETTER OF CONCERN AND WE LOOK
FORWARD TO FURTHER CONVERSATION
MOVING FORWARD. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR THE TESTIMONY.
NATURALLY LOWER THE LINE OF A
ONE FIFTY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD EVENING
MISTER CHAIR AND COMMITTEE
MEMBERS GIVING UP LEMMINGS ON
BEHALF OF PACIFIC GAS AND
ELECTRIC COMPANY IN OPPOSITION-
BUT LIKE THE BANK SENATOR
MCGUIRE AND HIS STAFF. FOR THE
CONSTRUCTIVE DIALOGUE WE HAD ON
THE BILL AND EFFORT THAT DATE
MAY TO TAKE OUR CONCERNS INTO
ACCOUNT- WE LOOK FORWARD TO
CONTINUING THE DIALOGUE TO
ADDRESS OUR CONCERNS AND-
SUPPORT BUT AS THE BUILDING.
TODAY THE PUBLIC THANK YOU.
NEXT WE'RE GONNA GO TO THE LINE
OF ONE FIFTY THREE PLEASE GO
AHEAD YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS THE LENI
HUNTER ON BEHALF OF THE COURT
WE SHARED A SIMILAR CONCERNS%
EXPRESSED BY OUR FRIENDS AT
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA EDISON AND
PACIFIC GAS ELECTRIC WE DO LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH SENATOR
REQUIRE AND SIXTEEN. TO TRY TO
ADDRESS THOSE CONCERNS. AT THIS
POINT WE ARE POST VERY GOOD
THANK YOU. AND RIGHT NOW WE
HAVE NO ONE ELSE IN Q. IF YOU
WOULD PLEASE JUST OPEN THE
LINES ONE MORE TIME AND REMIND
ANY OF THOSE WILLING TO WISHING
TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION TO SB
THIRTEEN. PLEASE CERTAINLY
WAITED A MONTH PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO IF YOU'D LIKE TO QUEUE UP.
IN OPPOSITION ONCE AGAIN IT'S
ONE ZERO. HELLO IN A FEW
MOMENTS WE DO NOT HAVE ANYONE
IN Q. THANK YOU MODERATE OR
APPRECIATE THE GOOD WORK. THANK
YOU TO ALL THE SUPPORT AND
OPPOSITION WITNESSES WILL NOW
BRING THE DISCUSSION BACK TO
MEMBERS WITH ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS OF THE AUTHOR. YES
SENATOR HERTZBERG. BERMAN IT'S
NICE TO SEE HIM STRETCH SENATOR
TO BURKE THANK YOU HEY
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS. SENATE
YES SENATOR BRADFORD. YOUR
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND I
WANT TO THANK THE AUTHOR FOR
ALL IT'S HARD WORK ON IN THIS
ON THIS EFFORT BUT- I AM REALLY
TORN HERE BECAUSE- PUBLIC
SAFETY IS A PRIORITY OF EACH
AND EVERYONE OF US ARE HERE AND
IN THIS LEGISLATIVE BODY AS
WELL AS TO UTILITIES TO
RESPONSIBLE FOR PROVIDING
SERVICES. BUT IT TOO NOW BURDEN
THE UTILITY. WITH ACTION YOUR
BARRIERS AND- REQUIREMENTS WHEN
IT WAS THIS LEGISLATIVE BODY
TWO YEARS AGO. THE U. S. B.
NINE OH ONE THAT REQUIRED HER
TO UTILITIES TO DO NOW WHAT
THEY'RE BEING CRITICIZED FOR
DOING. WE ASK OUR SHUT OFFS WE
ASKED FOR POWER SHOT UPS TO THE
DEGREE THAT THEY HAVE NOW TRULY
I THINK OUR FOCUS SHOULD HAVE
BEEN ON INFRASTRUCTURE REPAIR
AND VEGETATION MANAGEMENT BUT
WE ASKED TO FOCUS ON POWER SHUT
OFFS AND NOT TO UTILITIES HAVE
DONE. AND NOW TO NOW LIES DOWN
FOR DOING WHAT WE ASK THEM TO
DO NOT A SINGLE I OWE YOU OR-
PUBLICLY OWNED YOU TO. US FOR
THIS MEASURE BECAUSE HAVE BEEN
TURNING OFF POWER FOR DECADES
UNDER MY SISTER WAY SINCE WE
REPAIR WORK AND THEY HAVE. DONE
A BENSON. UNTIL IT BASS IN YOU.
FIRES ARE FAR DIFFERENT THAN
REGULAR INTEREST REPAIR BUT
NONE THE LESS I THINK THEY'VE
DONE THE BEST THEY COULD DO
UNDER THE CIRCUMSTANCES IN
WHICH THEY WERE DIRECTED BY
THIS LEGISLATIVE. BODY IT ALSO
STATES THAT REPAIR SHOULD NOT
BE BURDENED WITH THE COST
DURING POWER SHUT OFF AT NO
TIME WAS I AWARE THAT A UTILITY
EVER CHARGES YOU IF YOUR METER
IS IT TURNED IF YOU'RE- AN
ELECTRON. YOU'RE NOT PAYING FOR
THAT ELECTRIC BUT DIDN'T GO
ACROSS TO OUR INTO YOUR HOME OR
YOUR BUSINESS. YOU PAY FOR BACK
CAN. SERVICE SECTOR. COST BUT
THAT OUTLOOK TRON ITSELF YOU
DON'T PAY FOR IT WAS A THE- NOW
TO TALK ABOUT. ANY I'M A BIG
PROPONENT OF RULE TWENTY I WORK
FOR UTILITY AND I ADVOCATED
STRONGLY FOR RULE TWENTY FOUR
WE HAVE TO UNDERSTAND THERE'S A
RULE TWENTY EIGHT ZERO TWENTY
BEES. WROTE TWENTY SEATS. IF
YOU ARE A- GROUNDING HUNDREDS
OF MILES OF. TRANSMISSION WIRES
ON PRIVATE PROPERTY OR ON STATE
OR FEDERAL PROPERTY. THE
PROPERTY IN WHICH IS BEING
UNDERGROUND THEY PAY FOR NOT
RATE PAYERS SO WE NEED TO
UNDERSTAND THERE'S NO FREE RIDE
HERE'S SO EITHER THE LITTLE AN
OWNER HAS TO BEAR THOSE COSTS
OF UNDERGROUND AND UTILITY
SHOULDN'T BE FORCED TO DO THAT.
AND WE TALK ABOUT SERVICE
RELIABILITY EVERY TIME YOU DO
UNDERGROUND FACILITY THAT THE
LADIES ROOM HERE'S WE NEED TO
UNDERSTAND THAT ADDS A LONGER
DURATION OF THE OUTRAGE FROM
UNDERGROUND VERSE WERE HAD
FACILITIES SO FOR THOSE REASONS
I'M I'M I'M JUST. DâN I BRING
MY HOPE TO SUPPORT IT I
UNDERSTOOD AND INTENTIONS OF
THE- AUTHOR AND I KNOW. GENUINE
ANNE'S COULD BY. IT'S HARD FOR
ME TO GET TO YES WHAT WHAT IS
BEFORE ME TODAY SO THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SENATOR BRADFORD
OTHER QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
SENATOR PAN AND THEN WE'LL ASK
A SENATOR MARK. MCGWIRE TO
RESPOND AND CLOSE. SENATE PAN.
THANK YOU OF ACTUALLY I WOULD.
APPRECIATE IF CENTER REQUIRED
COULD DRESS PARTICULARLY THE
CONCERNS OF THE COALITION
CALIFORNIA TO THE EMPLOYEES-
DAY EXPRESSING CONCERNS ABOUT-
US THEIR WORK IS VERY DANGEROUS
SO APPRECIATE. THAT AT. MY
SISTER REQUIRED THIS IS THE
DEEPER DESPAIR PROPER TIME FOR
HIM TO RESPOND. THANK YOU
SENATOR PAN- SENATOR REQUIRE
WOULD YOU LIKE TO RESPOND IN
CLOSE. THANK YOU SO MUCH AS THE
CHAIR THANK YOU CENTER PANTS
AND A RED. I DON'T THINK THAT
ANYONE OF US TODAY. WHO LIVES
IN IS P. JEANNIE SERVICE
SURGERY. WOULD RAISE THEIR HAND
AND SAID. THEY DID A HELL OF A
JOB. LAST YEAR. WE CAN'T DEFEND.
UTILITY CAN'T DEFEND. WE'RE
HERE TODAY WE'RE HERE TODAY AND
WE'RE ABOUT TO GO INTO OUR NEXT
POWER SHUT OFF SEASON BECAUSE
IN PARTICULAR WITH P. JEANNIE
THE LACK OF INVECTIVE
INVESTMENT IN MISMANAGEMENT
WHEN IT COMES TO LACK OF
INVESTMENT GRADE HARDENING.
SEXUAL LIES ATION VEGETATION
MANAGEMENT AND MODERNIZATION
THAT'S THE BOTTOM LINE. IF YOU
GO IN TALK WITH THEIR TOP
EXECUTIVES. THEY'RE GONNA SAY
ESPECIALLY IN THE VEGETATION
MANAGEMENT AND ON THE
MODERNIZATION THEY'RE BEHIND
THIS YEAR. LET'S TAKE A LOOK AT
THE ALTERNATIVE THAT WE'RE
GONNA SAY TO NORTHERN
CALIFORNIANS. HE GOT TEN YEARS
OF THIS. TEN YEARS. IT'S
UNACCEPTABLE SO WHAT THIS BILL
DOES IT EXPEDITES RIGHTFULLY SO
IT EXPEDITES THE GRID HARDENING
THE MODERNIZATION THE SECTION
LIES ATION AS WELL AS THE
VEGETATION MANAGEMENT. END
LET'S TALK ABOUT THE FIFTEEN
PERSONAL LINES. THIS STATE
ISN'T TELLING THE UTILITIES
WHICH ALIGNS THEY HAVE TO TAKE
UTILITIES WORK WITH THE PUBLIC
UTILITIES COMMISSION IT'S IN
THE BILL THE WORK WITH THE
PUBLIC UTILITIES COMMISSION ON
WHICH LINES THEY'RE GOING TO
FOCUS ON EMPIRE TICE BASED OFF
OF WHERE THOSE POWER SHUT OFF
TO WAR. THERE IS NO LANGUAGE IN
THIS BILL THAT FORCE IS
UTILITIES TO BE ABLE TO FOCUS
ON ONE SPECIFIC LINE IT'S TEN
PERCENT. AND ITS FOCUS OVER
FIVE YEARS WE CUT THE TIMELINE
IN FIVE YEARS IF I'M A
CALIFORNIAN I THINK THAT'S-
THREE YEARS TOO LONG. BECAUSE
IT ENDED OR P. JEANNIE AND
AUNTS ARE SPEAKING SPECIFICALLY
ABOUT P. JEANNIE HAS SAID IS
THEY'RE GONNA CUT THEIR FOOT
PRINT THIS YEAR BY 30% 30% IT'S
NOT GONNA HAPPEN. WHAT HAPPENED
SO TALKING ABOUT NINE OH ONE
THIS LEGISLATURE 100% GAVE
UTILITIES RIGHTFULLY SO THE
AUTHORITY TO BE ABLE TO TURN
OFF THE POWER IN HIGH FIRE RISK
PART OF THE SEASON. IT'S NOT
SUPPOSED TO BE THEIR PRIMARY
TO. THE REASON WHY P. GENIE IS
HAD TO USE IT AS A BLUNT
INSTRUMENT IS BECAUSE THEY
HAVEN'T KEPT UP WITH THE
MODERNIZATION THE GREAT
HARDENING ERIN AND OR THE
VEGETATION MANAGEMENT THEY HAVE
NO OTHER TOOL TO BE ABLE TO
USE. THAT'S THE BOTTOM LINE.
AND WHEN IT COMES TO THE ISSUE
OF. HOW WE'RE HERE IF YOU SEE
ALSO HAS TO TAKE SOME
RESPONSIBILITY THE LACK OF
SUPERVISION BY THE PUBLIC
UTILITIES COMMISSION HOLDING
THEM ACCOUNTABLE THAT'S ANOTHER
REASON WHY WE'RE HERE. AND IT'S
JUST BE CANDID CLIMATE CHANGE
NOW AS EXASPERATED THIS
PROBLEM. BACK IN 20001215% OF
P. GENIES LINES WERE IN A HIGH
FIRE RISK ZONE TO DAY TO DAY IT
IS HALF. SO WHAT I THINK WE
NEED TO DO TODAY IS TELL THOSE
FOLKS WHO WE WORK FOR. AVERAGE
CALIFORNIANS WORKING JOES THAT
WE'RE GOING TO HOLD THIS
UTILITY ACCOUNTABLE. I FIRMLY
BELIEVE THAT WE'RE GOING TO
NEED TO MAKE SOME ADDITIONAL
MINUTES AND YOU KNOW ME I WILL
WORK WITH ANYONE AND EVERYONE
WE'VE ALREADY TAKEN SIGNIFICANT
AMENDMENTS. AND I PROMISE YOU
WE'RE GOING TO CONTINUE TO WORK
ON THIS BILL BUT I GOTTA TELL
YA I DON'T THINK THERE'S ANYONE
IN THIS LEGISLATURE RIGHT NOW
THAT WILL STAND UP AND DEFEND.
TEACHING THESE ACTIONS WE HAVE
TO MAKE SURE THAT WE HOLD THEM
ACCOUNTABLE IN WORK WITH THE
UTILITY- BOTH THE ELECTRICAL
WORKERS IN A CORPORATION TO
KEEP PEOPLE SAFE WE ALL WANT TO
ACT WE CAN DO IT IN HALF THE
TIME IN THE CASE. THAT THIS
UTILITY IS. WE ASK. THANK YOU
SENATOR MCGUIRE SEEING NO
FURTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE IS
THERE A MOTION. WE HAVE A
MOTION FOR SENATOR STERN-
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL AND-
PLEASE WE TO YOUR MICROPHONE IS
ON BEFORE SPEAKING. SB THIRTY
TWELVE BY SENATOR MCGUIRE DO
PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS. SENATOR HILL HI
SENATE HILL AYE FOR LOCK.
BRADFORD CHIANG. DOLLY. DODD HI
TODD I HERTZBERG ALRIGHT. IT
WAS NOT I THANK YOU HERTZBERG I.
MCGUIRE. MCGUIRE HI MCGUIRE I
PAN I PAN I. RUBIO I RUBIO I
SKINNER BY SKINNER I STERN BY
STERN I WIENER. ALL RIGHT
WIENER I. NINE A IS THE BILL
HAS NINE VOTES FOR WE WILL HOLD
THE ROOM OPEN FOR THE ABSENT
MEMBERS- AND- THANK YOU SENATOR
REQUIRE WILL NOW MOVE TO OUR
FINAL ITEM ITEM NUMBER SIX
SENATE BILL FOURTEEN FORTY
EIGHT BUT THE GOOD SENATOR
BRADFORD THERE YOU DO RIGHT
THERE. THANK YOU MISS YOUR I'VE
START OFF BY SAYING I ACCEPT
THE COMMITTEE AMENDMENT TONIGHT
THANK YOU CHAIRMAN STAFF THE
WORK THAT WE'VE DONE SO FAR AS
BE FOURTEEN FORTY YEAH FORTY
EIGHT WILL HELP SOLVE THE
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT GAP THAT
IS HAMPERING CALIFORNIA'S
WILDFIRE MITIGATION WORK IT
WILL ADDRESS SOME OF THE
CONCERNS OVER JUST DESCRIPTION
A LOT THIS BILL THE WALL FOR
THE TO YOUR PROPOSED RULE OF
UTILITIES TO TWENTY WHILE FAR
MITIGATION PLANS. THEY OWN. AS
QUOTED A LOT. DURATION PRESS IN
SOME OF GO FOR FOUGHT
SIGNIFICANT NUMBERS OF
EXPERIENCED PERSONNEL.
PARTICULARLY IN VEGETATION
MANAGEMENT. THE INDEPENDENT
WHILE FIRE SAFETY ADVISORY
BOARD ALSO RECOMMENDED IN A PRO
THAT THE P. YOU SEE CONSIDER
WHETHER THE UTILITIES ARE
DEVELOPING A ROBUST TRAINING
PROGRAMS. THAT ONE TRAIN
WORKERS TO IDENTIFY HAZARDS
THAT COULD IGNITE WILDFIRES. IN
TO INCREASE THE POOL OF
QUALIFIED ELECTRICAL WORKERS.
CLEARLY WE NEED MORE QUALIFIED
PERSONNEL WORKING A WILDFIRE
MITIGATION. WHERE COULD WE FIND
INDIVIDUALS WHO CAN JOIN THIS
WORKFORCE WHO ALSO HAVE
RELEVANT EXPERIENCE A GOOD
PLACES WE CAN DO IS START WITH
OUR LOCAL CONSERVATION STATE
CONSERVATION CORES AS WELL AS
OUR CDC ARE FAR CAMPS MEET MEN
AND WOMEN WHO ARE ON THE
FRONTLINE OF MANY OF THE FIRES.
AS FOURTEEN. THE SUPPORT HOW
THEY DEVELOP A WORK NECESSARY.
FOR WHILE FIRE MITIGATION THIS
BILL ALSO REQUIRES THEM TO
INDICATE THE EXTENT TO WHICH
THEY ARE HIRING SKILLED
INDIVIDUALS FROM CONSERVATION
CORES AS WELL AS FROM FIRE
CAMPS AND CREWS THIS BILL IS
NOT ONLY GOOD FOR INCREASING
SAFETY AND REDUCING TRAINING
COSTS BUT IT ALSO INCREASES
DIVERSITY IN WORK FORCE PEOPLE
IN CONSERVATION CORES AND IN
FIRE CAMPS ARE OFTEN BLACK AND
BROWN INDIVIDUALS. GET MORE
EXPERIENCED PEOPLE AND DIVERSE
INTO THE POPULATION TO THE
WILDFIRE PREVENTION WORK FORCES
GOOD. FOR THE BOTTOM LINE AND
IT'S THE RIGHT THING TO DO FOR
CALIFORNIA FOR THESE REASONS
AND MANY MORE HOUSE FOR A VOTE
ARE ON THE PHONE SHOULD BE
BRENDA. BRENDAN SMITH EXACTLY
DIRECTOR FOR STREAM FAR
RECRUITMENT PROGRAM. VERY GOOD
I THINK. YES HI- I'M HERE IN
YOUR HEARING WE CAN HEAR YOUR
HE'S PROCEED THANK YOU OKAY
CODE THANK YOU WILL SO MY NAME
IS BRANDON SMITH I AM THE
DIRECTOR OF THE FORCE OR EMPIRE
RECRUITMENT PROGRAM. WE GO LIVE
AFTER FOUR P. WE ARE AN
ORGANIZATION- THAT HELPS FOLKS
WHO ARE PREVIOUSLY INCARCERATED
EMPIRE CAN'T TRANSITION INTO
GAINFUL EMPLOYMENT. ONCE THEY
COME HOME- ONE OF THE REASONS
WHY I AM PASSIONATE ABOUT THIS
IS BECAUSE I HAVE A LIVED
EXPERIENCE. I REMEMBER BEING
EMPIRE CAMP AND- IN MAKING THE
DECISION THAT. I CAN GO HELP
OUT THE COMMUNITY AND WE WILL
MOVE FORWARD- I TRANSITION TO
BECOME A PROFESSIONAL
FIREFIGHTER WITH THE FOR
SERVICE DURING THAT ONE OF THE
THINGS THAT THAT THAT WE'RE
WE'RE OUT HERE. AND WE
RECOGNIZE THAT THERE IS A LABOR
FORCE. WHO IS AVAILABLE I KNOW
THERE ARE FOLKS ON THIS CALL
WHO COME FROM THE UTILITY
COMPANIES- THERE IS A FACT
THERE IS A WAY THERE IS A
PROCESS TO WHERE WE CAN GO HELP
OUT TO PROVIDE THE LABOR.
EXCUSE ME YOU ALL BUT YOU KNOW
30% OF THE STATE'S FIREFIGHTERS
OF FOLKS WHO ARE CURRENTLY
INCARCERATED. BUT WHEN THEY
COME HOME THEY DON'T HAVE ANY
OPPORTUNITIES. OR A LITTLE
OPPORTUNITIES TO TRANSLATE THAT
MOVING FORWARD. THAT'S ONE OF
THE THINGS THAT WE DO SO I HAVE
OUR P. IS HERE AMPLE SUPPORT
SENATE BILL- FOURTEEN FORTY
EIGHT- WITH SENATOR BRADFORD.
AND WE ARE ALSO HERE TO.
ACKNOWLEDGE AND RECOGNIZE THAT
HEY- IF UTILITY COMPANIES IF
FOLKS NEED LABOR TO GO MAKE
THIS HAPPEN ONE OF THE THINGS
IS WE ARE HERE TO GO. HELP OUT
SO THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MISTER SMITH CREATE YOUR
TESTIMONY TODAY. LOOKING IN THE
GALLERY IS THERE ANYONE HERE
WISHING TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF
SB FOURTEEN FORTY EIGHT. PLEASE
THANK YOU CATHERINE BRANDENBURG
REPRESENTING CINEMA CLEAN POWER
IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU FOR THE
TESTIMONY TODAY ANYONE ELSE IN
THE GALLERY SEE NO ONE WILL
MOVE TO- ROOM TWENTY FORTY IS
THERE ANYONE THAT HER FISHING
TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT. NO NO ONE
IS THERE'S WISHING TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT WILL NOW MOVE TO THE
TELLER CONFERENCE SERVICE
MODERATOR IF YOU WOULD PLEASE
PROP THE INDIVIDUALS WAITING TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT. SENATE BILL
FOURTEEN FOR IT WE WILL THAT.
OKAY ONCE AGAIN IT'S ONE ZERO
IF YOU'D LIKE TO QUEUE UP IN
SUPPORT. ONE ZERO. OUR FIRST
WILL COME FROM THE LINE. TWO
FOUR FOUR TWO HUNDRED FORTY FOR
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI KATIE IN NATALIE MAX
ON BEHALF OF AN ANSWER REGIONAL
OPEN SPACE DISTRICT IN
COMMUNITY NATURE CONNECTION AND
SUPPORT ALSO ON BEHALF OF THE
COMMITTEE AT THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF LOCAL
CONSERVATION CORPS IS WOULD
LIKE TO SUBMIT IF THE COURT THE
MEDITATION. WOULD LIKE TO
SENATOR BRADLEY BRADFORD FOR
WORKING WITH US ON AMENDMENT
DISTRICT THE LOCAL COR ABILITY
TO PROVIDE WORKFORCE TRAINING
IN HOW TO DETERMINE THAT-
INCLUDED IN SB FORTY FORTY
EIGHT GOING FORWARD THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR THE
TESTIMONY. WE'RE GOING TO THE
LINE. ONE THIRTY SIX PLEASE GO
AHEAD. AND EVERY KARAGANDY
HAPPEN FOR UTILITY REFORM
NETWORK TURN IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU. AND WE HAVE NO FURTHER
LINES IN Q. I ASK YOU PLEASE IF
YOU WOULDN'T MODERATOR OF.
PLEASE ASK IF THERE'S ANYONE
ELSE WISHING TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF SB FOURTEEN FORTY
EIGHT PAGE. ONCE AGAIN IF YOU'D
LIKE TO QUEUE UP IT IS ONE ONE
ZERO FOUR SUPPORT ONCE AGAIN
ONE ZERO. WE HAVE KNOWING
QUEUING UP IN SOME MARKETS
THANK YOU MODERATE OR
APPRECIATE THAT WILL NOW MOVE
TO THE OPPOSITION THE SENATE
BILL FOURTEEN FORTY EIGHT IS OR
ANYONE IN THE GALLERY WISHING
TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION. SEE NO
ONE IS THERE ANYONE IN ROOM
TWENTY FORTY NO ONE IS IN
TWENTY FORTY WISHING TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION WILL NOW GO TO
THE TELECONFERENCE FROM. IN
SERVICE- OF OPERATOR PROMPT THE
INDIVIDUALS WAITING TO TESTIFY
IN OPPOSITION THE SENATE BILL
FOURTEEN FORTY EIGHT AND THEN
WE WILL BEGIN WITH THEM. OKAY
ONCE AGAIN. LIKE TO QUEUE UP TO
OPPOSE IT IS ONE ZERO. SO FAR
WE DO NOT HAVE ANYONE QUEUING
UP. VERY GOOD THANK YOU IF YOU
COULD ASK ONE MORE TIME I
APPRECIATE IT. OKAY THAT IS IN
GERMAN TO OPPOSE PLEASE PRESS
ONE ZERO TO QUEUE UP. AND WE DO
NOT HAVE THE ANYONE IN Q. VERY
GOOD THANK YOU VERY MUCH. WE
WILL NOW MOVE TO- TO THE CREEK
BRING THAT ISSUE BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE IS THERE ANY ROOM FOR
COMMENTS OR DISCUSSION OR
QUESTIONS SENATOR DOT THE BILL
WAS FOR A PREVIOUS TRIGGERED
THANK YOU SENATOR DODD WE HAVE
NO QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS-
SENATOR BRADFORD WOULD YOU LIKE
TO. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN%
THIS IS A TREE FOR MEASURED ALL
ABOUT INCREASE IN OUR WORK
FORCE WITH QUALIFIED MEN AND
WOMEN HURT WILLING ABLE. AND
ARE READY TO GO TO WORK AND IT
ALSO IS ABOUT DIVERSITY IN
THEIR WORKFORCE AND IT'S ALSO
ABOUT MEETING MANY OF THE
CHALLENGES THAT WE'RE FACING.
DURING THE WILDFIRES BY HAVING
FOLKS WHO ARE SKILLED AT. NOT
ONLY VEGETATION MANAGEMENT BUT
ALSO- FRONTLINE- EXPERTISE
COMBATING. MANY OF THESE. ARE
HORRENDOUS WILDFIRES IN ON THAT
I ASKED BEFORE I WROTE VERY
GOOD THANK YOU SENATOR BRADFORD
PROMOTION ON IT SHOULD BE ABOUT
FORTY FORTY. SO SENATOR DODD OF
SORRY YOU SENATOR DONE PAULA
JUDGE FOR THAT. WE HAVE A
MOTION AND A PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. SB FOURTEEN FORTY EIGHT
BY SENATOR BRADFORD TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS.
OTHER HELP HI HILL BY MORE LOT.
BRADFORD AYE BRADFORD AYE CHEN
FIVE CHIANG I ALI BY DOLLY I.
DOT HI DODD I. HERTZBERG
HERTZBERG AYE MCGUIRE. MCGUIRE
HI. PAN HI CAN I. RUBIO HI
RUBIO HI. SKINNER SKINNER I
STERN HI STERN I. WIENER ALL
RIGHT WIENER HI. TOP EIGHTIES.
THE BILL HAS EIGHT VOTES IT IS
A HOAX SHARKS TWELVE EIGHTY
THREE TWELVE AM SORRY. THE BILL
HAS TWELVE VOTES AND IT IS OUT.
WHEN I GO BACK AND CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. ITEM NUMBER
ONE. PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS SB TEN FIFTY EIGHT BY
SENATOR WESSEL TO PASS AS
pAMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS.
CURRENT VOTE EIGHT THREE.
HERTZBERG ALL RIGHT HERTZBERG
HI REQUIRED REQUIRE I. TEN ETS
THREE KNOWS THE THAT BILL IS
OUT ITS BE CHANNEL TEN FIFTY
EIGHT IS WITHOUT ITEM NUMBER
TWO SB TEN SIXTY NINE PEOPLE
THEY HAVE TO MEMBERS SB TEN
SIXTY NINE BY SENATOR JACKSON
DO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS CURRENT VOTE
SEVEN TO. BRADFORD CHIANG.
HERTZBERG FIVE HERTZBERG AYE
MCGUIRE. MCGUIRE HI I. REQUIRE
I. BRADFORD BARBARA BRADFORD I.
TEN ETS TO KNOWS THE BILL IS
OUT SB TEN SIXTY NINE MOVING ON
TO ITEM NUMBER THREE SB ELEVEN
THIRTY PLEASE CALL THE AFTER
MEMBERS SB ELEVEN THIRTY
BALLINA GONZALEZ DO PASS AS
AMENDED TO. APPROPRIATIONS THAT
VOTE TEND TO. I **** MY APOLOGY
SIR WE HAVE ALL THE VOTES ON
THAT BUT WE DO HAVE THAT ONE
I'M SORRY THE- I PLEDGES
HERTZBERG HI. HERTZBERG EYEING.
ELEVEN A LOT OF WINDOWS SB
ELEVEN THIRTY IS OUT I REMEMBER
FOR SB TWELVE FIFTEEN FISCALLY
AFTER MEMBER. SB TOP FIFTEEN BY
SENATOR STERN DO PASS AS
AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS.
CURRENT VOTE EIGHT ZERO. TOP
AND ON AND ON HERTZBERG I
HERTZBERG AYE. NINE EIGHT ZERO
KNOWS THE SB TWELVE FIFTEEN IS
OUT ITEM NUMBER FIVE SB
THIRTEEN TWELVE PLEASE CALL THE
AFTER MEMBER. HAITIANS CURRENT
VOTE NINE ZERO ON THE. SENATOR
TRAINING ABOUT A CHANCE NINE
HERE. YEAH THE SECOND VOTE NINE
ZERO I THINK ALL OF OUR MEMBERS
WERE. WE'RE HERE SO ALL SENATOR
DEVOTED A- GOT MORE LOTS.
BRADFORD CHIANG. DOLLY. NINE
ZERO SEVEN NINE ZERO- SB
THIRTEEN TWELVE IS OUT AND ITEM
NUMBER SIX SB FOURTEEN FORTY
EIGHT IS OUT AS WELL THANK YOU
TO ALL THE INDIVIDUALS WHO
PARTICIPATED IN PUBLIC
TESTIMONY TODAY IF YOU WERE NOT
ABLE TO TESTIFY PLEASE SUBMIT
YOUR COMMENTS OR SUGGESTIONS IN
WRITING TO THE ENTERED THE
SENATE ENERGY UTILITIES AND
COMMUNICATIONS COMMITTEE OR
VISIT OUR WEBSITE YOUR COMMENTS
AND SUGGESTIONS ARE IMPORTANT
TO US AND WE WANT TO INCLUDE
YOUR TESTIMONY IN THE OFFICIAL
HEARING RECORDS THANK YOU AND
WE APPRECIATE THAT
PARTICIPATION. THANK YOU TO
EVERYONE FOR YOUR PATIENCE AND
COOPERATION TODAY WE HAVE
CONCLUDED THE AGENDA AGENDA THE
SENATE COMMITTEE ON ENERGY
UTILITIES AND COMMUNICATIONS IS
A GERMAN.